programming throwdown episode 76 code documentation take it away patrick i'm so excited to be doing another full episode again or i guess they're all episodes, but a non-interview episode. I'm trying to get a bunch of topics off of the chest. That's true. Yeah, we should. There's definitely some interviews that are kind of in the pipeline. There's nothing immediate. But yeah, we definitely are really getting caught up on a lot of a lot of our like focused episodes i guess so
Programming Throwdown 第 76 期：代码文档。Patrick，开始吧。我很高兴能再次录制一期完整的节目，或者说，虽然它们都是节目，但这期不是访谈节目。我积攒了一堆想聊的话题。确实。是的，我们应该聊聊。虽然目前没有什么迫在眉睫的访谈，但确实有一些访谈正在筹备中。不过，我们确实在补上很多我们想做的专题节目。
to speak or non-interview episodes and yeah if people have suggestions now's a good time to hit us up because um you probably won't have an interview next month either so but also i feel like people might groan a little and be like code documentation really you guys are scraping the bottom of the barrel but jason suggested this and i thought about i actually think like i don't know i'm kind of excited to talk we'll see how it turns out but yeah i mean this is one of the most important things because other things you know uh if we talk about specific languages maybe you're never going to use that language ever but this affects everybody and hopefully uh yeah and i think it affects it affects everyone who's programming pretty profoundly, a lot more than you think.
也就是非访谈类节目。如果大家有什么建议，现在正是联系我们的好时机，因为下个月可能也不会有访谈。但我感觉大家可能会抱怨说：“代码文档？你们真是江郎才尽了吗？”但这是 Jason 提议的，我考虑了一下，其实我觉得……我不知道，我挺期待聊这个的，看看效果如何。但这确实是最重要的事情之一，因为如果我们谈论特定的语言，你可能永远都不会用到它，但文档会影响到每个人。我希望，而且我认为这会深刻地影响每一个程序员，比你想象的要深远得多。
It's one of these sort of, like you don't really imagine other people reading your code. Like even just thinking about it, it's kind of weird. Just thinking about somebody else, just like trying to figure out what your code is doing. But that happens all the time. And so even though we might not think about it um and so documentation um i feel like we have a really a lot of good things to say about it so so the first thing i want to talk about is uh system design questions on an interview and i'll do a little like what that means and why and then i'll let you go first jason but um the to me if you're doing an interview and lots of
这是一种你不会真正想象别人在阅读你的代码的情况。即使只是想到这一点，也觉得有点奇怪。想到有别人在试图弄清楚你的代码在做什么。但这经常发生。所以即使我们可能不会去想它，但我感觉关于文档，我们有很多好的观点要分享。所以，我想谈的第一件事是面试中的系统设计问题。我会简单介绍一下它的含义和原因，然后让 Jason 先说。但对我来说，如果你正在面试，而且很多
people you know listen are either looking to get a job in computer programming or graduating college and looking to get a job or um even just i think i actually think it's good to interview every so often just so you sort of get practice with it even though i don't always do it as much as i as as much as i should and it is a lot of work but it is one of those things I think being prepared to interview is always sort of good. And a system design question is instead of the expectation,
听众要么正在寻找编程工作，要么刚大学毕业在找工作，或者我甚至认为，偶尔参加面试是件好事，这样你可以练习一下，尽管我做得不如我应该做的那么多，而且这很费力，但我认为为面试做好准备总是有好处的。系统设计问题不是那种期望
at least at many tech companies, if you interview for a programming job that you have to do coding on the whiteboard, the infamous whiteboard, or even just on a computer or something. System design is saying, hey, let's move
在许多科技公司，如果你面试编程工作，你必须在白板上写代码，那个臭名昭著的白板，或者甚至是在电脑上。系统设计则是说，嘿，让我们提升一个层次，不再是写一个 30 到 45 分钟就能完成的程序，而是讨论你如何设计某个东西。虽然可能还是在 30 到 45 分钟内，有些公司可能会在这个问题上花更长时间，但这是一个更高层次的问题，涉及更多的动态部分，通常不涉及写代码。是的，完全有道理。我们在节目开始前简单聊过这个，但我做的是机器学习，如果听过我们机器学习节目的朋友可能都知道。
this up a level from writing a program that you can do in 30, 45 minutes to talking about how you would design something. And still maybe in 30, 45 minutes, sometimes some companies will do it a little bit longer for this question, but it's sort of a higher level question with more moving parts and often doesn't involve writing code. Yep, totally makes sense. So we were talking about this a little bit before the show, but I do machine learning, as probably a lot of people know if you listened to our machine learning episodes.
但我们实际上有一个专门针对机器学习的系统设计面试，它更多地关注统计学，比如你如何设计它以使其更稳健，如何收集正确的统计数据等等。正如 Patrick 所说，你并不真正需要写很多代码，你可能会在白板上画一些图表之类的，但它真正关注的是你如何从高层次处理问题。大多数时候，我寻找的是——这也取决于经验水平——那些过去犯过错误，并且已经在设计系统时预先考虑到这些错误的人，或者那些一开始就试图弄清楚问题的局限性和范围的人。
But we actually have a separate system design that's focused on machine learning that deals a lot more with statistics, like how do you sort of design it to be a little bit robust how do you collect the right statistics things like that and um yeah as patrick said you don't you're not really expected to write a lot of code you might whiteboard some diagrams and things like that um but it's really about how you tackle things at a high level and what most of the time we're looking for like what i'm looking for is and it depends on the levels of experience too but i'm looking for people who've kind of made kind of mistakes in
并确保他们不会过度设计或设计不足。我们稍后会详细讨论这一点。所以它可能和系统设计面试非常相似，只是主题不同。是的，举个例子，我在一家拥有大型互联网业务的公司工作，或者说任何科技公司，你都会期望遇到与分布式系统相关的问题。举个例子，如果你拿一个电子商务网站来说。
the past and are already kind of preemptively you know trying to design the system with those in mind or you know people who start off trying to figure out the limitations and the scope of the problem and things like that. And sort of making sure they don't over-design, under-design, and things like that. And we'll talk about that in a little bit more detail. So it's probably pretty similar to a system design interview, just with a different topic. Yeah, so maybe an example for me, you know, working at a company that has, or I guess any tech company that has a large internet presence, you know, you would expect to get a question that has something to do with distributed systems. So an example of that might be, you know, if you take an e-commerce site or whatever.
我不喜欢点名，因为我不想……我不知道任何细节，但如果只是举个例子，比如亚马逊。人们很熟悉亚马逊的界面。它有一个产品页面，当你访问时，它可能会显示过去一天有多少人购买了这个产品。他们其实没这样做，但也许他们想这样做。也许他们想增加一个功能：当你访问这个盐瓶的网页时，显示“这个盐瓶昨天卖出了 10,000 个”。他们认为这会给你带来……他们管这叫什么？
I hate naming names because I don't actually, you know, particularly want to, I don't know anything about the details, but if you just say it as an example, like Amazon or something. So Amazon has, you know, people are familiar with kind of the UI. So, oh, it has a product page and on a product page, you know, you go there and it might want to say how many people bought this product in the last day. They don't do that, but maybe they want to. Maybe they want to add a feature. When you visit a web page for this particular kind of salt shaker, this salt shaker was sold 10,000 times yesterday. And they think that'll give you, what did they call that?
看到别人也做出同样决定所带来的社会认同感。他们会问你，你如何设计这个功能？这是一个开放式的问题。有很多种处理方式。所以第一件事是确保你理解他们想从你这里听到什么。如果你是网页设计师，
The social benefit of seeing that other people are making this decision as well. And so they'll ask you, how do you design that? And so they're really, it's open-ended. There's lots of ways you can take this. So the first thing is to make sure you kind of understand the kinds of things they're interested in hearing from you. If you're a web designer,
也许他们想看你如何决定把它放在页面的什么位置，或者如何设计样式。如果你面试的是基础设施职位，你可能会开始思考：好吧，这是亚马逊。他们有很多人访问网站。当它显示“昨天有 10,000 人购买”时，这是指过去 24 小时吗？数据的实时性要求有多高？还是指从午夜到午夜的一整天？我们如何计算它？如何收集它？
maybe they're looking for how you would figure out where on the page to put it or how to style it. If you, you know, are interviewing for an infrastructure job, you might start thinking about, okay, this is Amazon. They get a lot of people coming to the website. When it says yesterday, 10,000 people bought that, Is that yesterday in the trailing 24 hours? And then how fresh does that need to be? Or is it in a bucketed, the last, you know, sort of midnight to midnight day? And how do we compute that? How do you collect it?
如何生成它？存储在哪里？亚马逊有数百万种产品，所有产品都需要这个值。这是在用户加载网页时计算，还是在滚动基础上预先计算并存储在数据库中？如果需要数据库，数据库需要分片吗？查询会是什么样子？抱歉，我其实不是在
How would you produce it? Where would you store it? So Amazon has, I don't know how many products, millions of products, and all of them need this value. Is it something you would compute when a person loads up the web page? Or is it something that you would pre-compute, you know, on sort of a rolling basis and store in a database somewhere? And if that database, does that database need to be sharded? What would the query look like? Sorry, I'm actually not
给出答案，只是提出了更多问题。但这些是你开始尝试的方向。面试官可能会根据情况给你更多细节，也可能不会。他们可能会说：“哦，其实我们有一个 SQL 数据库，我们想让你写一个 SQL 查询来计算它。”好吧，那其实不算系统设计。所以这是一个糟糕的例子。但他们可能会说：“好吧，亚马逊有十亿种产品。你如何为十亿种产品计算这个值？”
giving answers. They're just giving more questions. questions but um you know these are the kind of directions you would start trying to take it in and the person you know depending on the interview the person may give you more details or they may not they may say you know oh yeah actually what what we have is you know we have a in a sql database and we'd like you to write a SQL query to figure it out. Okay, well, that's not really, I guess, system design. So that's a bad example. But they might say, okay, yeah, so it turns out Amazon has a billion products. How would you compute this value for a billion products?
而且它必须是即时计算的，因为我们不想为那些不热门的产品浪费资源。是的，完全正确。这其中很大一部分是，如果有人说：“我想为每种产品都计算一下。”你会说：“看，变动太大了。我们的库存有数以亿计的产品，其中很多可能已经停产了，或者虽然在库但没人看，我们甚至没有足够的资源。即使有，也是巨大的浪费。”然后你得看
And it should be computed instantaneously because we don't want to compute it for not popular products. Yeah, exactly. That's a big part of it is if someone says, oh, you know, I want to like compute it for every product. Well, you say, well, look, there's so much churn. We have our inventory is, you know, a gazillion products, a lot of which are maybe even discontinued or they're technically there, but no one looks at them and that, you know, we don't even have enough resources. And even if we did, it'd be a huge waste. And then you have to see like, okay,
候选人是否会适应并说：“哦，有道理。我没考虑到这一点。让我们保留某种缓存。”所以，使用直写式缓存（write-through cache）或者类似的术语，总之就是某种缓存，当你第一次访问该产品时进行计算，也许放一个填充数字或空值，但你在计算它。这样下一个人访问时……以此类推。如果有人只是说“这就是我想到的，我坚持我的想法”，即使它是错的，那可能就不是一个好的答案。
is the candidate going to adapt to that and say, you know, Oh, that's a good point. I didn't think about that. Let's keep some kind of cash. So, and, and, you know, have a right through cash or is that the term anyways, have some kind of cash where, you know, when you hit the cache or is that the term? Anyways, have some kind of cache where, you know, when you hit the product the first time of that day, you have to do some computation and maybe you put a filler number there or empty or something, but you're computing it. And so then when the next person goes, et cetera, et cetera, if someone just says, well, that's the thing I thought of and I'm sticking to it, even though it's wrong, that's probably not a good answer.
所以总的来说，在系统设计面试中要非常灵活。是的，我认为这是对的。我觉得不知道某件事没关系，但正如 Jason 指出的，如果你坚持己见，当有人说“我需要它在 24 小时滚动窗口内计算，精确到最后一秒”，你不能说“这看起来很蠢，我认为我们应该每天午夜计算一次，运行一个巨大的批处理作业来计算所有东西”。那不是一个好的回答。我确实见过有人试图那样做，或者试图强行将其纳入自己的舒适区。但实际上，你真的要确保你在回答面试官提出的问题。
So one thing in general is to be very adaptable especially in the system design interview yeah I think that's right I mean I think it's okay to not know something but as Jason pointed out to just like stick to your guns and if someone says you know oh I need it computed in the rolling 24 average hour the rolling 24 hour window uh and i you know you know computed to the last second or something you can't be like well that seems dumb uh i think we should just compute it each night at midnight we'll run a giant batch job and compute it for everything uh that would not be a good yeah i mean i have seen people try to do that or try to force it into their comfort zone um but in reality you really want to make sure you're answering the question the person's asking
是的，这在一般情况下是正确的，但在设计面试中尤其如此。面试官有一条特定的路径，或者说一段旅程，他们想带你走。如果你偏离了那段旅程，这真的会影响你通过面试的能力。所以我以前也遇到过这种情况，有人真的想让我使用像 MapReduce 这样的分布式处理系统。他们说：“你必须对这些数字进行排序。”我说：“你可以找一台机器。现在有两 TB 内存的机器了。”
yeah that's a that's the thing that's true in general but especially for design interviews is the interviewer has a certain path that they a journey if you will that they want to take you on and and if you deviate from that journey you know it can really impact your you know ability to kind of pass the interview right so so if someone says oh and i've done this before i've been on the receiving end of this where someone really wanted me to use uh like a distributed processing system like MapReduce. And they said, well, you know, you have to sort these numbers. And then I just, I was like, oh, you can get a machine. Now they have machines with two terabytes of RAM or whatever it was at the time.
我说：“所以你可以做到。你可以在一台机器上完成。”他说：“如果它只有 1GB 内存呢？”我说：“好吧，你可以使用文件，仍然可以在一台机器上完成。”事实是，那个人想让我进入分布式计算领域。最终我明白了，但要试着从面试官那里读取线索，
I was like, so you could do it. You could just hold down one machine. And he's like, what if it only had a gig of RAM? And I was like, okay, well, you could have files and then you could still do it on one machine. And the reality is a person wanted me to go into distributed computation, right? At some point I figured it out, but try to read the cues from the interviewer
因为他们想引导你走向某个方向，在那里他们会有很多后续问题。但我知道的一件事是——至少对于我这种不常处理数据库和互联网服务的人来说——就是对那些我传统上不认为是“写 SQL 查询”的数据库方面的舒适度。我的意思是，写 SQL 查询很重要，我也在日常编程中推崇它们的价值。但我认为，理解在大科技公司——或者说大型云服务公司或互联网公司——所面临的权衡也很重要。我不知道，那些拥有庞大网络业务的公司，通常不止一种数据库。实际上有很多种数据库。这是我以前没意识到，但对很多分布式处理问题都很重要的事情。正如 Jason 提到的，MapReduce 是分布式计算，如果你要运行分布式计算，不可避免地要存储数据。所以，如何拥有能被大型 MapReduce 进程访问并存储数据，如何处理
because they're going to want to sort of steer in a certain direction where they're going to have a lot of follow-up questions and things like that. But the one thing that I, know for i guess i don't know at least the background i came from uh not working a lot with sort of databases and internet services is the whole comfortableness with the aspects of database that aren't what I would have traditionally considered like writing SQL queries. I mean, writing SQL queries are important and I've espoused their value in, in everyday
流式数据，哪些需要强一致性，哪些需要最终一致性。最终一致性到底是什么意思？你如何进行查询负载均衡？系统的哪些部分应该是状态化的，哪些是无状态的？是的，所以如果你想为这些面试做准备，很重要的一点是看看那家公司是做什么的，因为它几乎肯定会围绕那个领域展开。在面试前思考一下公司 X 最大的技术挑战是什么。比如如果你在面试 Google，
programming. But I mean, I think that also just understanding the kinds of trade-offs that at a big tech company, or I don't keep, I keep saying tech company, I guess a big cloud computer company or internet company. I don't know people who have a lot of large web presence. Um, there normally isn't only one kind of database. There are actually many kinds of databases. And this is something that I didn't realize and is important to a lot of distributed processing questions. So as Jason mentioned, like map reduces distributed computation well if you're going to run distributed computation inevitably you want to store it um and so how to have data that can be accessed by big map reduce processes and stored from large map reduce processes things for
去从事他们的搜索算法工作，那么你可能需要处理大量数据，并在数据中进行查找。如果你面试的是 Tesla，去设计汽车传感器之类的，那将是一个非常不同的系统设计。所以大多数人会问直接相关的问题。我知道我在做机器学习设计面试时，其中一个问题就是：“这是我们公司的一部分，如果我们必须从零开始，你会怎么做？”这基本上就是任何系统的本质。当然也有一些通用的系统设计问题，但即便如此，它们也会围绕那家公司正在解决的技术或问题展开。是的，这建议很好。如果我必须给建议，不像其他事情，你可以去编程竞赛
streaming data things that need to be strongly consistent versus eventually consistent. What does eventually consistent even mean? You know, how do you, you know, like load balance queries? What parts of the system should be stateful versus stateless? Yeah, so I guess like, so if you want to prepare for one of these interviews, one big thing is, is, you know, look at what the company does, right? Because it's almost certainly going to,
网站做一些示例题，这个有点不同。我认为它涉及更多的阅读和思考。正如 Jason 指出的，一个很好的起点是了解公司是做什么的。但对我来说，在宏观层面上可能有帮助的是理解目前使用的数据库种类及其区别。不是 MySQL 和 Postgres 之间的区别，那可能是两种实现方式相似的数据库。而是像 Cassandra（最终一致性）和 MySQL 之间的区别，以及为什么你会选择其中一个而不是另一个？这是一个研究领域。此外，数据是如何索引的。Jason 提到了 Google 搜索，所以理解什么是反向索引，如何进行网络爬虫？当你做网络爬虫时，如何以一种对搜索有用的方式存储数据？你如何进行字符串匹配，比如
you know, revolve around that. Think about like, what are the biggest technical challenges at company X before you interview? Like if you're interviewing at, I'm just making stuff up like companies up, but if you're interviewing at Google, you know,
当有人开始在 Google 搜索中输入一个词，它试图猜测你要搜索什么，然后当你拼错单词时，它如何匹配？这是如何工作的？你如何为超大数据集做到这一点，并且速度非常快？我认为这些通用主题涵盖了……我不想说涵盖了所有或大部分，但我不知道有什么更好的建议列表能涵盖更多。是的，总的来说，几乎每家公司都有某种前端，可能你是在接入现有的系统，比如为 Salesforce 编写插件。
to work on their search algorithm then yeah you're probably going to need to deal with handling a lot of data and looking for things in the data and things like that if you interview at uh maybe like tesla to design you know a sensor on a car or something it's going to be a very different system design and so most people are going to ask questions that directly relate. I know when I do the ML design interviews, one of the questions is literally, here's a piece of our company.
所以你是在编写将在 Salesforce 中渲染的模式，或者其他应用。也许你在构建自己的应用，比如移动应用。也许是网站。也许是所有这些。所以了解那家公司的“人类界面”是什么，然后思考另一端，他们需要存储什么信息，然后你如何连接这两部分，这是一个
How would you start it over if we had to start over from scratch? And that's basically going to be the essence of almost any system. There's definitely some generic system design questions um but even then they're going to revolve around whatever technology or whatever problems you know that company's solving yeah that's really good advice and if if i had to give i don't know unlike other things that it's something you can just go to you know a programming competition
很好的思考方式。所以这是一种……如果你是自顶向下或自底向上的思考者，你可以从任何一端入手。但只要记住，你有宇宙的两端，你必须设计中间的一切。是的。机器学习系统设计也差不多。我们会问一些问题，比如亚马逊有“相关产品”。当你访问一个产品页面，它显示“顾客也查看了”
website and do some example problems this one's a little different i think it involves more reading thinking like jason pointed out a great starting point is what the company does but i mean i think for me the big thing that probably helps in a broad stroke fashion is understanding the kinds of databases currently used and what the differences are and not like the difference between, uh, my SQL and Postgres, like those are probably two kinds. They're, they're the same kind of database. They're just two implementations of a similar kind. Um, but what's the difference between like Cassandra, which is eventually consistent and my SQL and why would you use one over the other? So that's like one area of research. Also, how data is indexed. So Jason mentioned like Google search. So understanding what a reverse index is and how would you do web crawling? When you do web crawling, how would you store the data in a way that's useful for doing search? How do you do string matching on, you know,
或与此相关的项目，你如何高效地设计它？或者如果有人访问主页，你如何快速获得推荐，但亚马逊有数以亿计的商品目录。你如何快速选择最相关的三个项目等等？
someone enters the, starts entering a word into google search and it tries to guess what you're going to search um and then how does it match that when you misspell something like how would that work how would you do that for very large data sets and do it really fast um those kind of general topics i think cover i don't know i want to say cover everything or most but i don't know of a great set of recommendations that would cover more yeah i mean in general you know almost every um company you know has i guess it depends on yeah i would say almost every company has some kind of front end like maybe um you're plugging into some existing system, like you're writing a plugin for Salesforce.
所以它很相似。只是它带有一点统计学色彩，或者说随机性。因为如果你去 Google 输入“猫”，你肯定需要看到猫，对吧？也许是关于猫的维基百科页面，我其实不知道第一个出现的是什么。但在这种情况下，你偶尔出错也没关系。如果你没有推荐最好的东西，亚马逊不会崩溃。
And so you're, you know, you're writing Salesforce, you know, you're writing some schema that's going to be rendered in Salesforce, right? Or some other app. Maybe you're building your own app, like, you know, mobile app. Maybe it's a website. Maybe it's all of those things, right? And so it's good to know like that company what is their interface their human interface right and and then think about all the way on the other side what sort of information do they need to store and then how can you sort of connect those two pieces like it's a
但平均而言，你希望做得越来越好。所以出于这个原因，它有点不同。但有趣的是，它们也有很多相似之处。其实，输入“cat”会给我 Yahoo Finance 上 Caterpillar 公司的股票代码，但右侧有关于猫这种动物的知识图谱卡片。哦，好的，然后有一个指向维基百科的链接。是的，第二个结果是维基百科。哦，原来如此，酷。那么，进入新闻环节，除非你还有别的事。不，你刚才急着想知道我的……现在我要查“狗”。等等，不，我开玩笑的。它们是平等的吗？Google 的工程师是猫派还是狗派？让我们查查。好吧，我们继续。我的第一条新闻也与之相关。
good way to think about it so it's a sort of and it's candles if you're a top down or bottom up kind of thinking person you can you can approach it from either end but yeah just think you have these that's the two ends of the universe and so you have to design kind of everything in between right yep um yeah so ml ml system design is is pretty similar i mean we'll ask things like, you know, for example, Amazon has the related products. So when you go to a product that says, oh, you know, maybe customers also viewed this
它是关于如何搞定面试的。这真的是非常、非常、非常好的建议。如果你计划再次参加面试——希望很多人都会，除非你退休了——你一定要看看这个视频。你知道，在我们的案例中，我们进行或参加的很多面试都非常技术化。我们想雇人，人们也想雇我们做某事。通过电话很难了解一个人的能力。所以很多建议，这位先生甚至一开始就说，如果你在现场面试，他们已经有了你的简历，他们已经想雇你了。这是关于如何确保他们喜欢你。而且，
or related to this item, you know, how would you sort of design that efficiently? Or if someone goes to the homepage and you get some recommendations quickly, but Amazon has a catalog of, you know, a zillion items. So how can you choose the three most relevant items in a quick fashion and things like that?
至少在科技行业，这不一定是真的。有很多候选人我们来到现场时还不确定是否要雇佣他们，但这些建议仍然非常非常相关。简单总结一下，我会加入我自己的体会，因为虽然我今天看了，但我当时有点忙。你知道，我给予了它充分的关注。但一定要积极、充满活力、乐于沟通。此外，你提到你有几个故事，我认为这非常有用。所以，他说，事先准备几个与你想要的工作相关的个人故事。即使它不是
So it's kind of similar. It just has a bit more of a statistics, maybe like a stochastic bent to it in a sense that if you go to Google and you type cat, you definitely need to see a cat, right? And maybe out of the Wikipedia page for cat, I don't actually know what comes up first. But in this case, you know, you could be wrong some portion of the time. If you don't recommend the best thing, you know, Amazon's not going to crash and burn.
针对特定公司的，但假设你想成为一名银行家。好吧，也许你经营过一个柠檬水摊，你收集了钱，管理得非常好，当别人工作时，他们不知道发生了什么，摊位就倒闭了之类的。但他建议，要有一个好的叙事，要有好的故事，围绕为什么你注定要从事这种工作。我是在转述。一定要看看那个视频。那只是其中一个建议。
But just on average, you want to be doing better and better. And so it's a little bit different for that reason. But actually, there's a lot of similarities too interestingly cat gives me the stock ticker on yahoo finance for caterpillar company but at the knowledge graph card on the right for cat animal oh okay and then has a link to wikipedia or something yes yeah second result is wikipedia oh there you go cool so on to on to news unless you have anything else no you were dying to know what my now i'm gonna do dog hang on no i'm just kidding are they are they equal are google employees engineers cat people or dog people let's find out i'm just let's move on all right uh, my first news story is kind of related.
但我认为这真的非常有趣。这些是我一直相信的事情，但我无法很好地表达出来，并将其转化为一套简洁的要点。如果你要参加面试，我绝对会去看看。从第一个大型……你查到“狗”了吗？什么狗？不，我没有。我这就查。好吧，迷人的播客。避免 else，尽早返回。这在今天早些时候流传，但它触动了我的……
It's, um, how to crush an interview. Um, this is really, really, really good advice. If you're, if you ever plan on interviewing again, which hopefully is a lot of people, unless you're retired, um, uh, you should definitely, definitely check out this video. Um, you know, the thing is in our case, a lot of our interviews that we give or that we attend are very technical, right? We want to hire people and people want to hire us to do XYZ. And it's very hard to know the person's competency over the phone. So a lot of this advice, he even starts off, this gentleman starts off by saying, if you're at the onsite interview, you know, they have your resume, they already want to hire you. This is how to make sure they like you. And that's, you know,
所以我认为现在聊聊很好。这是一篇关于编码风格的博客，很多人习惯于在函数底部只有一个 return 语句，并使用巨大的 if-else 语句来处理所有事情，最后在底部返回。他们说，他们过去也这样做，但现在已经放弃了。他们现在的做法是，如果检查发现有问题，就直接尽早返回。如果代码向下走，在中间返回是有意义的，他们就会返回。总之，在任何有意义的地方返回，而不是使用那些尴尬的 if-else。
at least in tech, that's not true. There's a lot of people who we don't know if we want to hire them when they come on site, but still, uh, a lot of the advice is like really, really relevant. Just to kind of like summarize it quickly. And I'll add my own flavor here a little bit because because even though I watch it today, I was kind of busy. You know, I was giving it full attention. But but, you know, definitely be positive, be energetic, be kind of open to communication. Also, you mentioned you have a few stories, which I thought was like profoundly useful. So, you know, he said, you know, beforehand, come up with a few life stories that are relevant to whatever job you want. I mean, even if it's not,
在 Reddit 和 Hacker News 上阅读了很多关于此的评论，很多人说他们也被教导过这种方式。我意识到，我以前也是这样被教导的：你真的应该只在底部有一个 return 语句，这样代码最易读，尽早返回是有问题的。我思考了一段时间，试图弄清楚这是怎么回事。有一些评论提到了这一点，我意识到，如果你使用的是 C 语言并进行内存分配，或者进行多线程编程且有锁，如果你有多个 return 语句，你需要确保内存不会
you know, specific to a specific company, but let's say you want to be a banker. Well, maybe you ran, and I think the example he gives, you ran a lemonade stand and you collected money really manage the stand very well and and when people were working other than you they didn't know what was going on and the stand collapsed or something right um but he's like you know kind of have that good narrative and um you know have kind of good stories that you know revolve around why it's almost like you're kind of destined to be doing this type of job. And I'm kind of paraphrasing here. Definitely check out the video. That was just one of the tips.
泄漏，你需要确保释放操作已完成，或者锁已解锁。如果你尽早返回，审计代码并确保每条路径都释放了资源，这在有多个 return 语句时确实更难做到。所以我认为这更多与此有关。但后来意识到 C++ 有 RAII（资源获取即初始化），在其他语言中，有作用域锁之类的东西，使得很多这种问题消失了。当你返回时，实例和变量的锁会自动处理。你有更多的结构允许你更安全地从不同地方返回。我不知道为什么这种奇怪的残留范式还在学校里被教授，
But yeah, I thought it was really, really interesting. It's stuff that I've always believed, but I couldn't really kind of articulate it this well and kind of turn it into this sort of like uh a very concise you know set of points and uh yeah i definitely would check it out if you're ever going to interview getting off of interviewing from the first uh large well did you look up dog yet what's dog no i didn't here i'll do it right now okay fascinating podcasting um avoid else return early this was uh circulating earlier today actually but it it kicked off something in my Okay. Fascinating podcasting. Avoid else return early. This was circulating earlier today, actually, but it kicked off something in my mind,
或者其他地方。我想人们认为在底部有一个 return 语句更易读，但实际上，这可能只是因为在必须审计资源的情况下才更易读。但现在你不需要那样做了，它就不再适用了。所以没有太多反驳的声音，大家都 100% 同意。是的，我认为任何时候只要能避免嵌套括号，总是好事，对吧？
so I thought it was good to talk about now. This is an article, a blog, about how from a coding style that a lot of people do this notion of only having one return function or one return statement at sort of the bottom of the function and having big if-else statements for handling everything and then returning at the bottom. And they were saying, you know, that they used to do this, but they basically have ditched it. And now what they do instead is, you know, if they check something and there's a problem, they'll just return early. And if they go down somewhere else and it makes sense to return they'll return in the middle and then you just return wherever it makes sense instead of sort of having these awkward if what they were sort of saying these awkward if else um and the
是的。但我前几天还在想，我陷入了这样的困境。比如，“天哪，我这里有一堆尴尬的提前返回。我真的需要重构它，把所有返回都移到底部。”但今天再想，我其实不确定我是否真的觉得嵌套括号更多的代码更
reading a lot of commentary on sort of reddit and hacker news about this people a lot of other people were saying you know that they also had been taught this and then i was realizing you know i was taught this as well like that you really want to only have a return statement at the bottom that this leads to the most readable code that the early return statements are problems and i actually thought about it for a while and tried to figure out what was going on here um and there were some comments this effect and what i realized is that i think if you're doing a sort of language like C and doing memory allocations and you return early or if you're doing multi-threaded programming and you have a lock and you have many return statements you need to make sure memory doesn't
易读。事实上，有时如果你用 if-else 绕了很久，追踪逻辑并不比直接处理并返回更容易。是的，我的背景非常不同，显然我没做过嵌入式开发。除了现在我有一个机器人项目。所以从我的背景来看，更多是如果你有递归或某种递归方程或任何类型的归纳，你会说你的基准情况。
link you need to make sure your deallocations are done your destructions are done or that your locks are unlocked and if you return early auditing the code and saying that i know every code path frees its uh whatever resources it's acquired um that that's tougher to do with multiple return statements and so i think that it has more to do with that but then realizing c++ with you know raii resource acquisition is initialization um in other languages uh having you know sort of scoped locks and these kind of things make a lot of this sort of go away that as you return that the instances and the variables in this locking you do you have more constructs which allow you to do these returns from various places safer and i think that for some reason that it just sort of never caught up that there's still this weird lingering paradigm being taught in school or
我到了基准情况了吗？那就直接返回。换句话说，如果我在做斐波那契数列之类的，就是“我到序列末尾了吗？好的，返回 0”。然后“我没到基准情况，那就进行递归并返回结果”。所以，是的，如果你在做任何类型的动态规划或递归或人工智能相关的东西，你总是那种思维模式：有一个基准情况，直接退出，否则就做其他事情。
whatever i guess that you should have this return statement at the bottom and that it's somehow more readable when in reality it was probably more readable given if you have to audit for this other stuff. But now that you don't have to, it doesn't. So there wasn't a lot of rebuttal saying, oh, no. Yeah, I agree 100%. Yeah, I think it's like anytime you can avoid having, you know, like, what's it called? Like having nested brackets. It's always a win, right?
所以，当我看到那种代码时，是的，它看起来好多了，所有返回都在前面，清理掉所有你关心的案例。所以，也许对于嵌套 if-else 确实有一些好的反驳理由，在某些情况下，如果你确实需要以提到的方式审计代码，且没有更好的结构，那可能是合理的。但目前我感觉也许我应该放弃在底部保留单个 return 语句的残余习惯。我不知道为什么要坚持它。
Yeah. But I was thinking just the other day, though, like I was in a conundrum like this. Like, oh, man, I have an awkward set of returns early here. I really need to refactor this to get all the returns down to the bottom. And then thinking about it today, like, yeah, I'm actually not sure that I do find that code with the more nested brackets more
是的，我对底层了解不多，但我觉得创建一个对象，它不可能占用那么多内存，比如创建一个空类之类的。所以你几乎总是可以使用作用域来做你需要做的事情。好吧，我有一个关于我今天整天都在做的工作的故事，关于我陷入的优化细节，那会让你起鸡皮疙瘩的。好吧，可能吧。天哪。所以，我的第二个故事是一个可爱的小信息图。它叫“宜家说明书”。基本上有人采用了宜家说明书的视觉风格和非语言风格。
readable and in fact sometimes it's difficult to know if you've kind of if else your way out of something for a long time like follow tracing that logic through the code is not easier than just like doing it and returning it yeah i mean my background is very different right obviously like i haven't done embedded things. Other than now, I have this robot project. And so from my background, it's more like if you have a recurrence or some kind of recursive equation or any type of induction, you say your base case.
如果你曾经组装过宜家的椅子、桌子或床，你知道在说明书的第一页，他们会展示所有的零件，以及最终成品的样子。他们一步步引导你，但每一步都只是为了展示某种动作，没有任何文字，没有标签。如果有的话，可能只是非常细微的，比如顶部有两种不同的螺丝。所以第一页可能会说：“看，这是螺丝 900，这是螺丝 901。”之后可能会引用这些数字，但除此之外几乎没有文字，全是图片。有人采用了这种风格，并将其视为一种艺术风格，
Am I at my base case? Then just return. So in other words, if i'm doing some kind of uh fibidachi sequence or something it's like okay am i at the end of the sequence okay just return zero and then it's like okay i'm not at the base case then do some recursion and return that and so it's like yeah i mean if you're doing any type of dynamic programming type stuff or recursive or a lot of ai stuff it stuff like you're always thinking in that mode where it's like you have some base case you're just bailing early otherwise you're going
解释了一堆计算机科学算法，比如快速排序之类的。它非常可爱，打印出来放在桌子上作为装饰，或者装裱起来会很不错。虽然我不认为你可以通过这种方式学习它们。我试着跟着看了几个，对于我本来就懂的算法，我觉得“哦，好的，我明白它在做什么”。但对于我不懂的算法，我不太确定我是否跟上了。是的，我知道。即使是看快速排序，我也能大概明白他们在说什么，但这一定是给那些已经懂的人看的，这只是个可爱的小东西。是的，别用这个来学习任何东西。所以我们要推荐两个 YouTube 视频，我想这
to do some other stuff and so yeah when i see like that type of code um yeah i mean it looks so much better with you know all the returns up front you know clearing out all the cases that you're interested in so i i mean maybe there is some good counter arguments for having the nested if else and in some cases if you do need to audit the code in in the way mentioned and there's no other way of like having better constructs that's probably reasonable but yeah i guess i i'm currently feeling like maybe i should abandon the vestiges of like having a single return statement at the bottom. Like, yeah, I mean, I'm not sure what the reason to cling to it is.
绝对是我们链接部分的记录。不错。但这东西我之前见过几次。但这个特别好。我一直对密码学很感兴趣。视频的名字是《用密码学发牌》，嘉宾是 RSA 加密算法的 Ron Rivest。它在 Numberphile 频道上。如果没看过，大多数人可能看过，这是一个超级受欢迎的频道。Numberphile 有数学视频，数学家或其他专家会简单地解释事物，它有自己的风格，很不错。
Yeah, I get I don't know too much about low level, but like I feel like creating an object, it can't possibly use that much memory, like creating a empty class or something. Right. And so you can almost always use scopes to do whatever you need to do there. Well, I've got a story about work I was doing all day today about the minutia of optimization I was getting into that would make your skin crawl then. Okay, probably. Oh, man. So, yeah, so my second story is, it's just a cute little infographic. It's called Idea Instructions. And basically someone took the visual style and the nonverbal style of IKEA instructions.
是的，我明白，我对底层了解不多，但我觉得创建一个对象，它不可能占用那么多内存，比如创建一个空类之类的。对吧。所以你几乎总是可以使用作用域来做你需要做的事情。好吧，我有一个关于我今天整天做的工作的故事，关于我陷入的优化细节，那会让你起鸡皮疙瘩的。好吧，可能吧。天哪。所以，是的，我的第二个故事，它只是一个可爱的小信息图。它叫“宜家说明书”。基本上有人采用了宜家说明书的视觉风格和非语言风格。
If you've ever built a chair or a table or a bed or anything out of IKEA, you know that there's, you know, in the very first kind of page of the instructions they kind of show you like these are all the parts uh and this is what you want at the end and they kind of walk you step by step but every step is meant to just like show some kind of movement but there's no uh uh you know words at all no labels if anything there might be like just very minute like at the top they might have two different types of screws and so the very first page might say look this is screw you know 900 and this is screw 901 and then later on it might refer to those numbers but other than that there's almost no text it's all just a bunch of pictures and someone kind of took that sort of style and really treated it like an art style and just a bunch of pictures and someone kind of took that sort of style and
如果你曾经用宜家的东西组装过椅子、桌子、床或任何东西，你就知道，在说明书的第一页，他们会向你展示所有的零件，以及最后成品的样子，他们会一步一步地引导你，但每一步都只是为了展示某种动作，没有任何文字，没有任何标签，如果有的话，可能只是非常细微的，比如在顶部他们可能有两种不同类型的螺丝，所以第一页可能会说，看，这是900号螺丝，这是901号螺丝，然后稍后可能会引用这些数字，但除此之外几乎没有文字，全都是一堆图片，有人采用了那种风格，并真正把它当作一种艺术风格，一堆图片，有人采用了那种风格，并且
really treated it like an art style and explained a bunch of computer science algorithms um like quicksword and things like that and it's it's pretty cute it'd be a good thing to print out and put like or get laminate not laminated but uh um like just put it on your desk as like a cute thing get it framed or something you do I wouldn't say you could learn them this way though I did try to follow a couple and for algorithms I knew I was like oh okay yeah I see what it's doing here but for algorithms I didn't I was like I'm not sure I followed this yeah I know no even like I'm looking at quicksort and like yeah I could kind of get what they're saying but yeah this has to be for people who already know what they're doing and it's just a cute thing yeah don't don't use this to learn anything so i we're gonna go for two youtube videos i think this is
真正把它当作一种艺术风格，并解释了一堆计算机科学算法，比如快速排序之类的，它非常可爱，把它打印出来放在桌子上，或者塑封一下，不，不是塑封，就是把它放在桌子上作为一个可爱的小东西，装裱起来或者什么的，你会这样做吗？不过我不会说你可以通过这种方式学习它们，我确实尝试跟随了几个，对于我了解的算法，我想，哦，好的，我明白它在这里做什么，但对于我不了解的算法，我想，我不确定我是否理解了这个，是的，我知道，甚至像我看着快速排序，是的，我能理解他们想表达什么，但是的，这一定是给那些已经知道自己在做什么的人看的，这只是一个可爱的东西，是的，不要用这个来学习任何东西，所以我们要看两个YouTube视频，我想这是
definitely a record for our link section nice um but this was sort of something I've that I'd seen a number of before. But this one was particularly good. It's something I've always been interested in in cryptography. And that is the name of the video is Dealing Cards with Cryptography with Ron Rivest of the RSA encryption algorithm. And it's on the Numberphile channel. If you've never watched this most people probably have it's a super popular channel but um number file has got like math videos where mathematicians or other people explain stuff simply and it's got its own style and it's nice
绝对是我们链接部分的记录，不错，但这确实是我以前见过的一些东西。但这个特别好。这是我一直感兴趣的密码学领域。视频的名字是“用密码学发牌”，主讲人是RSA加密算法的罗恩·里维斯特（Ron Rivest）。它在Numberphile频道上。如果你从来没看过这个，大多数人可能看过，这是一个超级受欢迎的频道，但Numberphile有一些数学视频，数学家或其他人在那里简单地解释事情，它有自己的风格，而且很好
easy watching um but this one has this famous cryptographer guy basically talking about how would you play a game of poker in the mail using the principles of cryptography and so he points out like well you know if jason and patrick want to play poker you know patrick has the cards patrick can't just shuffle the cards deal five for jason and deal five for himself because there's too much incentive for him to cheat i would just give oh yeah jason you totally all you got was three high terrible hand actually that would actually be good i only can get three high and not have got pairs i'm not a very good poker player seven high yeah right okay right all right okay good seven high yeah if it's uh what is it uh texas hold'em right uh i mean i think just like he i think his example is just whatever five card i'm not a poker person i think
轻松观看，但这一集里有一位著名的密码学家，他基本上是在谈论如何利用密码学原理通过邮件玩扑克游戏。他指出，如果杰森和帕特里克想玩扑克，帕特里克手里有牌，他不能直接洗牌，给杰森发五张，给自己发五张，因为他有太大的动机去作弊。我会说，哦，是的，杰森，你拿到的全是三点，真是糟糕的牌。其实那倒不错，我只能拿到三点，没能凑成对子，我不是个好的扑克玩家。七点，是啊，好吧，对，好吧，好的，七点。是的，如果是德州扑克，对吧？我的意思是，我想他的例子就是随便五张牌，我不是个扑克迷，我想。
just normal five card poker but basically like how does jason trust that i'm gonna you know shuffle the cards fair that we can compare fairly and it turns out yeah he wouldn't be able to do normally but if you use some of the things that are used for cryptography, and he actually sort of takes cards, puts them in envelopes, and places actual physical locks on the envelopes. And it's just really like I was watching it, and I don't know, maybe later I'll be like, why did I pick that for the show?
就是普通的五张牌扑克，但基本上就是杰森怎么能相信我会公平地洗牌，让我们能公平地比牌呢？结果发现，是的，他通常无法做到，但如果你使用一些密码学中用到的东西，他实际上是把牌放进信封里，并在信封上加上真正的物理锁。我当时看着这一幕，不知道为什么，也许以后我会想，我为什么要选这个作为节目内容？
But I was watching it. It was just hilarious because this is something I've always heard described but i've never seen someone take actual physical locks put them on envelopes and and sort of explain the algorithm that's awesome and of course he points out this is how computers do it they do it really fast they do it all the time this is in a way kind of how public key cryptography is done uh it's just done really fast and without real locks um but if you're curious about cryptography or just want to i i thought i found it humorous uh you can watch this uh ron rivest on um numberphile doing dealing cards with cryptography i think he has a number now i'm trying to remember i believe he's done other episodes on numberphile as well he's not the host
但我当时在看。这太搞笑了，因为这是我一直听说过但从未见过有人真的用物理锁锁住信封，并解释其算法的过程。这太棒了。当然，他指出这就是计算机处理它的方式，它们处理得非常快，而且一直在这样做。这在某种程度上就是公钥密码学的实现方式，只是速度非常快，而且没有真正的锁。但如果你对密码学感到好奇，或者只是想……我觉得这很有趣，你可以看看罗恩·里维斯特在Numberphile上做的用密码学发牌的视频。我想他现在应该有编号了，我在努力回忆，我相信他在Numberphile上还有其他剧集，他不是主持人。
um but he i think has made guest appearances on there several times um talking about other kinds of math and um he and explains in the video as well one of the ways that public key cryptography is done which is exponentiation modulo a factor without going in super details but if you've if you don't know anything about that uh then i would encourage you to to check it out cool yeah i will definitely watch this video right yes this show is done yeah well text me and tell me if i am like should delete this portion of the show and this is totally just that i had a weird quirk in finding it no this this sounds amazing this sounds really really fun it's not it's not a super long video and it is not going to teach you to get a job in cryptography so all right it might teach you not
嗯，但他我想他已经作为嘉宾出现过好几次了，谈论其他类型的数学。他在视频中也解释了公钥密码学的一种实现方式，即模幂运算，虽然没有深入细节，但如果你对此一无所知，那么我鼓励你去看看。酷，是的，我一定会看这个视频。对，是的，这个节目做完了。好吧，发短信告诉我，如果我觉得我应该删掉节目中的这一部分，或者这完全是因为我在寻找内容时有个奇怪的癖好。不，这听起来很棒，这听起来真的非常有趣。这不是一个超长的视频，它也不会教你找到一份密码学的工作，所以好吧，它可能会教你不要
to get a job book of the show book of the show my book of the show is hillbilly elegy which is um a really interesting book it was a bestseller um i just happened to be crawling the bestseller list and i thought this is something that is totally outside of you know what i would usually read and so i gave it a shot and i thought it was great um uh it's basically it's one of these things where like the the environment so it's a it's a non-fiction book it's about a real family so it's it's anecdotal um um and yeah the environment kind of is the book so without really spoiling anything let's just say like um uh basically okay after you know there's this there's this big industrial age there's there
去找工作。本期推荐书目，我的本期推荐书目是《乡下人的悲歌》，这是一本非常有趣的书，它是畅销书。我刚好在浏览畅销书榜单，我想这完全超出了我通常会读的内容，所以我试着读了一下，我觉得它很棒。它基本上是那种环境……这是一本非虚构类书籍，讲的是一个真实的家庭，所以它是轶事性质的。是的，环境就是这本书的核心。所以，在不剧透的情况下，我们只能说，基本上，在经历了那个巨大的工业时代之后，那里
was a lot of uh manufacturing jobs right? People working in like seal plants, things like that. A lot of those jobs kind of went away. And this is somebody who I think he grew up. So I think this person is probably in their 40s, I want to say. And so they're coming kind of on the tail end of that, or maybe they're younger than that but anyways so they're coming on the tail end of when a lot of those manufacturing jobs really went away and and it basically decimated this town and uh it talks a lot about uh you know a variety of these towns in appalachia which is uh people aren't from the u.s or people are don't know it's it's like kentucky kind of tenn are don't know it's like Kentucky, kind of Tennessee, Pennsylvania area.
有很多制造业工作，对吧？人们在钢铁厂之类的地方工作。很多这样的工作消失了。这是一个我认为他成长于其中的人。所以我想这个人大概40多岁，我想说。所以他们正处于那个时代的末尾，或者可能比那更年轻，但无论如何，他们正处于许多制造业工作真正消失的末尾，这基本上摧毁了这个城镇。它谈论了很多关于阿巴拉契亚地区各种城镇的情况，也就是……如果人们不是来自美国，或者人们不知道的话，它就像肯塔基、田纳西、宾夕法尼亚地区。
And just about kind of how they got decimated. Nobody really knows about them. They have a lot of pride as a people, but they're also like kind of suffering like immensely. And it really kind of talks about a lot of specific things like I I've driven through, you know, Kentucky and Tennessee and Pennsylvania, but never actually stopped in any of those states. And so I know very little about their culture. And so this was like a really interesting insight into that culture. And it really talks a lot about specifically like why some people in that area or maybe in the U.S.
谈论了它们是如何被摧毁的。没有人真正了解它们。他们作为一个民族有很多自豪感，但他们也正在遭受巨大的痛苦。它确实谈论了很多具体的事情，比如我开车经过肯塔基、田纳西和宾夕法尼亚，但从未真正在这些州停留过。所以我对他们的文化知之甚少。所以这对我来说是一个非常有趣的洞察，深入了解了那种文化。它确实谈论了很多关于为什么那个地区或美国的一些人
or broadly are struggling. And there's a lot of reasons why people are struggling. But if you were to ask me for, let's say, even 10 of them, I probably wouldn't even give one from this book because I didn't really think about things in this way. So it really is interesting. I mean, it's not an uplifting book, although, you know, it ends on a high note with some people really sort of making the best out of their situation.
或者更广泛地说，人们正在挣扎。人们挣扎的原因有很多。但如果你让我列举，比如说，哪怕是其中的10个原因，我可能一个都说不出来，因为我以前并没有这样思考过。所以它确实很有趣。我的意思是，这不是一本令人振奋的书，尽管它以一些人真正从困境中走出来的高调结尾。
But it's it's a pretty heart wrenching book, but super, super interesting. A great story. It really kept me engaged. It's, you know, I kind of tend to, you know, one day I know start reading a book or continue reading a book another day i'll do something else this book i just blitz through it because it really captivated me and i think part of it was that it was so different from what i usually read um so yeah i would highly recommend it it's it's it's a bestseller so it's it's really high quality and uh yeah i think it's a fantastic book i read it on audible nice i'm listening to oathbringer which is the third book in the stormlight archives trilogy by brandon sanderson i think i've had the other two books on here before i would love i actually have read a couple
但这是一本相当令人心碎的书，但超级超级有趣。一个伟大的故事。它确实让我沉浸其中。你知道，我倾向于……有一天我开始读一本书，或者另一天继续读一本书，我会做别的事情。这本书我是一口气读完的，因为它真的吸引了我。我想部分原因是因为它和我通常读的内容太不一样了。所以是的，我强烈推荐它。它是畅销书，所以质量非常高。是的，我认为这是一本很棒的书。我是通过Audible听的。不错，我正在听《誓约之剑》，这是布兰登·桑德森的《飓光志》三部曲中的第三本书。我想我之前在这里提到过前两本书。我很乐意……其实我读过几本
other books but i didn't really care for them. And I dislike giving like mediocre. I have done it a couple of times, but I'd rather talk about something I'm really enjoying. Yeah. Even if I have the choice. Right. Yeah. And so this one I'm nearly done with. So one of the things I want to point out is, first of all, this is the third book in a
其他的书，但我并不太喜欢它们。我不喜欢给出平庸的评价。我做过几次，但我宁愿谈论我真正喜欢的东西。是的。即使我有选择权。对。是的。所以这一本我快读完了。所以我想指出的一点是，首先，这是三部曲中的第三本书。
trilogy. And I just looked it up because I'm listening to it. It's 55 hours. This book, this book, the third book in a trilogy and i just looked it up because i'm listening to it it's 55 hours this book this book uh the third book um the others are almost as big and so this is a massive amount of like commitment to get through all of these and i was reading so i was curious it says the hardcover is about 1200 pages long for if that helps you think about like how big 1248 and i was thinking another book i did read an actual book form was anathem that i thought was like a very big book by neil stevenson and that one's only 937 pages so i'm not saying that like it's amazing just
我查了一下，因为我正在听它。它是55个小时。这本书，这本书，三部曲中的第三本书，我查了一下，因为我正在听它，它是55个小时。这本书，这本书，第三本书，其他的也差不多这么大。所以要读完所有这些书需要巨大的投入。我当时在读，所以我很好奇，它说精装本大约有1200页，如果这能帮你想象它有多大的话，1248页。我当时在想，我读过的另一本实体书是尼尔·斯蒂芬森的《七夏娃》，我觉得那是一本很大的书，而那本只有937页。所以我不是说它很棒只是
because it's really big but but it's taking me. I was shocked. It's actually taking me kind of a long time to get through it. Is that because it's our books on tape or audible books faster or slower than reading? I mean, I know it depends on the person, but like does an average person or you, for example, do you read? I read much faster than the audible narration. OK, even if it's because you know there's reading like skimming through something no no no like just my normal reading speed is okay quite a bit faster
因为它很大，但它确实花了我……我很震惊。它实际上花了我很长时间才读完。这是因为有声书比阅读更快还是更慢？我的意思是，我知道这取决于个人，但普通人或者你，例如，你读吗？我读得比有声书的叙述快得多。好的，即使是因为你知道有阅读，比如略读之类的……不，不，就像我正常的阅读速度也快得多。
i never really thought about it until now i mean i've never like raced i sure but i'm pretty sure even like i'm sure i could read slower if I wanted, but like even just reading at like an enjoyable pace for me, I'd be much faster. The thing for me, though, is finding time. I guess I'm just too distracted. But like finding time to sit down and actually read a book is tough. And so I tend to not get it in as long of periods versus it can take me 45 minutes or more to get home nearly every day uh and so that is a time when i can sit there and do my you know get quality time with a book yeah makes sense um and so for me uh you know even if i could read faster so like this is 55 hours it might only take you
我直到现在才真正想过这个问题。我的意思是，我从来没有比赛过，但我很确定，即使我想读慢一点也可以，但即使是以我舒适的节奏阅读，我也会快得多。对我来说，问题在于找时间。我想我太容易分心了。但找时间坐下来真正读一本书很难。所以我倾向于不会在很长的时间段内阅读，而我每天回家几乎要花45分钟或更长时间，所以那是我可以坐下来，做我的……和书共度高质量时光的时间。是的，有道理。所以对我来说，即使我能读得更快，比如这是55个小时，可能只需要你
i don't whatever i don't i don't know what the ratio would be because it depends on your speed maybe 20 hours yeah 20 or 30 hours but for me finding 20 or 30 hours to read this is just like i don't i don't currently have it scheduled in and so but i i enjoy the content a lot yeah and so but oathbringer i am like three hours left or something so oh wow i'm down at the finish line but i i i don't know that it's going to have an amazing ending or not, not quite at the end, end, end yet. But I've really enjoyed it so far. So you've talked to me about or talked to us in the past about, you know, world building versus kind of building story and things like that.
我不知道比例会是多少，因为这取决于你的速度，也许20个小时，是的，20或30个小时。但对我来说，找到20或30个小时来读这本书，我目前还没有安排出来。所以我很享受其中的内容。是的，所以《誓约之剑》我只剩下三个小时左右了，所以哦哇，我快到终点了。但我不知道它是否会有一个惊人的结局，还没有到最后、最后、最后。但我到目前为止真的很喜欢它。所以你过去和我谈过，或者向我们谈过世界构建与故事构建之类的事情。
Where does this fall in that sort of axis? So, I mean, if you have that much time or you know pages to go over something um so this is interesting uh i think this definitely qualifies as world building so it's very much about people and about stories but also about a lot of kind of you learn a lot about the world these people are living in um and one of the books i read that was a collection of uh short stories this is not the one i was saying i didn't like although i actually i'm not a big fan of short stories i don't feel i can get into them but um a lot of branders brandon
这在那个轴线上处于什么位置？所以，我的意思是，如果你有那么多时间或页数来讨论某件事……所以这很有趣，我认为这绝对属于世界构建。所以它非常关注人物和故事，但也关注很多……你了解了很多这些人所居住的世界。我读过的其中一本书是一本短篇小说集，这不是我说我不喜欢的那一本，尽管其实我不是短篇小说的忠实粉丝，我觉得我无法进入它们，但布兰登·桑德森的很多
sanderson's books take place in a sort of meta universe called the cosmere um anyways this is like super detailed i guess it doesn't matter but he has a bunch of books that sort of feel like you can just read them in isolation and they are in isolation except that it turns out they're all really in a bigger universe and there are like common traits about the bigger universe and so um there are sometimes eas eggs between the books, if you read between the books. And this collection of short stories has a lot more detail about sort of the behind the scenes inside baseball of, you know, kind of that thing. And so I think not only is he doing world building on like a per series basis, but he's also collectively building all of the worlds together into one universe that makes sense that sounds similar to like terry pratchett books right where
书都发生在一个被称为“寰宇”的元宇宙中。无论如何，这非常详细，我想这没关系，但他有很多书，感觉你可以单独阅读它们，它们确实是独立的，除了结果发现它们都在一个更大的宇宙中，并且关于这个更大的宇宙有一些共同的特征。所以，有时如果你在书之间阅读，会有彩蛋。而这本短篇小说集有更多关于那种幕后内幕的细节。所以我认为他不仅是在每个系列的基础上进行世界构建，而且还在集体地将所有世界构建成一个有意义的宇宙。这听起来类似于特里·普拉切特的书，对吧？
where you know there's a basically there's a there's a i guess an engine for lack of a better word with a set of rules and an environment there and all the books take place within the same engine um and so there are certain things that happen that seem kind of just serendipitous, but over time you start to understand how the engine works. And so then when you see that thing again, you're like, oh, even if it's in a different book, you kind of know what's really going on, and someone who that's their first book isn't getting it yet. So one of the examples of this is the number eight the number eight in terry pratchett books is uh you can't say it if you're a wizard
你知道，基本上有一个……我猜是一个引擎，缺乏更好的词，有一套规则和一个环境，所有的书都发生在同一个引擎内。所以发生了一些看起来很偶然的事情，但随着时间的推移，你开始理解引擎是如何工作的。所以当你再次看到那个东西时，你会想，哦，即使它在不同的书中，你也知道真正发生了什么，而第一次读那本书的人还不知道。其中一个例子是数字8，在特里·普拉切特的书中，如果你是巫师，你就不能说它。
so you have to do seven plus one is is uh you know two to the third or something like that um if you say seven plus one is eight and you get kind of struck down i can't remember exactly what it is and so there are just times where that comes up and eventually you read the handful of times in the series of books where um that's relevant but uh um but then there's still um you know other times where it happens and it's just kind of part of another story and uh and it just kind of happens and and uh if you know that you're like oh wow that's so cool like it's funny that just happened that guy got you know obliterated by a lightning bolt because he's the number eight but if it doesn't happen it just seems like just some serendipitous thing like what the lightning bolt struck that guy
所以你必须说七加一，或者二的三次方之类的。如果你说七加一等于八，你会被某种方式击倒，我不记得确切是什么了。所以有时会出现这种情况，最终你读了系列书中那几次相关的部分。但还有其他时候它发生了，它只是另一个故事的一部分，它就那样发生了。如果你知道这一点，你会想，哦哇，那太酷了。这很有趣，那个人被闪电击中了，因为他是数字8。但如果不知道，它看起来就像某种偶然的事情，比如为什么闪电击中了那个人。
down okay let's go on to the next thing yeah so i i to conclude i mean oathbringer is a really good book i i'm gonna recommend it even though i'm not finished with it yet but a little hard to give i haven't shared anything actually about the book yet but um i i it's hard to when it's the third book in a series so go check it out on i guess amazon or goodreads or wherever and and sort of read if you're interested in the summary or the back of the book. But you'd have to go to a bookstore to find the back of the book. So not going to recommend that. Right.
好的，让我们继续下一件事。是的，所以总结一下，我的意思是《誓约之剑》是一本非常好的书，我会推荐它，尽管我还没有读完。但很难给出……我还没有分享关于这本书的任何内容，但当它是系列中的第三本书时，这很难。所以去亚马逊或Goodreads或任何地方看看，如果你对摘要或书的背面感兴趣的话。但你必须去书店才能找到书的背面。所以不打算推荐那个。对。
And you could read that on Audible. And if you are if you're not an Audible member yet and you want to join, use our link that helps us out. You go to audibletrial.com slash programming throwdown all one word and if you are an audible member or or uh you want to support us in any other way you can go to our patreon um just an update on the patreon so i think we're set on the design um actually i'm going to print out tonight my printer actually broke but but yeah i got a i got a new printer yesterday and tonight i'm going to print out the uh uh you know all the thank you letters we're going to write we're going to stuff those in some envelopes along with um the emblem and uh we're going to start mailing those out hopefully uh you know
你可以在Audible上读它。如果你还不是Audible会员，想加入，请使用我们的链接，这会对我们有帮助。你去audibletrial.com/programmingthrowdown，全部小写。如果你已经是Audible会员，或者你想以其他方式支持我们，你可以去我们的Patreon。关于Patreon的最新消息，我想我们已经确定了设计。其实我今晚要打印出来，我的打印机坏了，但我昨天买了一台新打印机，今晚我要打印出所有的感谢信，我们要把它们和徽章一起塞进信封里，我们希望在几周内开始邮寄。
in a couple weeks yeah i also had laser cutter issues so i am lagging behind and getting all of the logos cut so but yeah it's gonna happen it will happen before the end of the year yeah yeah and uh you know every christmas we're gonna do this hopefully uh no you know we'll get it more stream well that we're not gonna do this we're half our hardware breaks but um you know every christmas we're going to do this giveaway you know i have had my printer break which sucked but uh overall you know it's been really fun just you know uh really i mean part of it's just looking up where people live like because you know we need your address to mail you at the emblem just seeing that we have people all
是的，我的激光切割机也出了问题，所以我切割所有徽标的进度落后了。但是的，这会发生的，它会在年底前发生。是的，你知道每个圣诞节我们都会这样做，希望……不，你知道我们会让它更精简。好吧，我们不会这样做，我们有一半的硬件坏了，但你知道每个圣诞节我们都会做这个赠品。你知道我的打印机坏了，这很糟糕，但总的来说，这真的很有趣。我的意思是，部分原因只是查找人们住在哪里，因为我们需要你的地址来邮寄徽章。看到我们有来自世界各地的人支持这个节目，真的很令人兴奋。
over the world who uh support the show is is really exciting um and being able to um you know make something and uh something kind of real and physical and send it off to the people who are listening is really cool and so we hope you all keep uh you know keep subscribing uh definitely tell us you can use the patreon chat which i which i follow you know i monitor whatever um tell us what you think once you get the envelope if you get it broken or something definitely let us know but in general we appreciate so much your support also if you're in russia where our podcast is banned not because of our podcast specifically but just our hosting provider is banned um if you're russian uh you can access the Patreon RSS which is super fast and works in Russia
能够制作一些真实、有形的东西，并把它寄给正在收听的人，真的很酷。所以我们希望你们都继续订阅。一定要告诉我们，你可以使用Patreon聊天，我关注它，我监控它。一旦你收到信封，告诉我们你的想法，如果它坏了或者其他什么，一定要告诉我们。但总的来说，我们非常感谢你们的支持。另外，如果你在俄罗斯，我们的播客被禁了，不是因为我们的播客本身，而是因为我们的托管服务商被禁了。如果你是俄罗斯人，你可以访问Patreon RSS，它速度超快，在俄罗斯也能用。
so nice tool of the show my tool of the show it's actually two but they both do the same thing iFunny and 9Gag so these are apps one is iFunny kind of like iPad like the letter iFunny
好的，本期工具。我的本期工具其实有两个，但它们的功能是一样的：iFunny和9Gag。这些是应用程序，一个是iFunny，有点像iPad，像字母iFunny。
but it works on Android and desktop and everything. The other one is 9, the number 9, gag. So 9-G-A-G. Both of these are just basically a feed of funny things. And you can kind of tailor it. It also kind of knows, based on your upvotes, it kind of sorts it accordingly.
但它可以在Android、桌面和所有设备上运行。另一个是9，数字9，gag。所以9-G-A-G。这两个基本上都是搞笑内容的推送。你可以定制它。它也知道，根据你的点赞，它会相应地进行排序。
You can also look up certain things. If there's a certain topic you want to follow. But it's just a list of really funny things. It's usually memes, usually like a picture with some text. It could be a video with a caption. But, you know, I'm one of these people, I really believe a lot in this idea that, especially when it comes to emotions, that we're all like much simpler than we would like to believe right and so if you just see something silly and laugh every day i think it actually will have a profound effect on your mood and even though it's it sounds like such
你也可以查找某些内容。如果你想关注某个特定主题。但这只是一个非常有趣的内容列表。通常是模因，通常是一张带有一些文字的图片。它可能是一个带标题的视频。但你知道，我是那种人，我真的非常相信这个观点，特别是在情感方面，我们都比我们愿意相信的要简单得多。所以如果你每天看到一些愚蠢的东西并大笑，我认为它实际上会对你的情绪产生深远的影响。即使听起来像是
a forced thing um and i wouldn't go into it saying like oh i need my funny medicine today or anything like that right but i just in general it's good to have like systems in place that you know may improve your life and for me this is one of these things like i have these apps um they send a notification like roughly every day and so i can kind of you know tap notification logs me in i get to see some really funny stuff and if i see something really funny you know i'll share it so occasionally patrick and other people get kind of random memes they're kind of like you know where did this come from and there's no context at all it's just something funny i saw in one of these apps
一种强迫性的事情，我不会说“哦，我今天需要我的搞笑药”之类的，但总的来说，拥有一些可以改善你生活的系统是很好的。对我来说，这就是其中之一。我有这些应用程序，它们大约每天发送一次通知，所以我可以点击通知，登录，看到一些非常有趣的东西。如果我看到非常有趣的东西，我会分享它。所以偶尔帕特里克和其他人会收到一些随机的模因，他们会说“这是从哪里来的”，完全没有背景，这只是我在这些应用程序中看到的有趣的东西。
um yeah and i think it's one of these things that really kind of um it'll let you sort of bond with other people too like especially like you might not have a reason to talk to aunt sue but you could always send aunt sue the video of that cat you know getting stuck to a ceiling fan or something like that now i'm gonna have to scroll through all of it no i'm just kidding so it's speaking of things that definitely don't waste your time um yeah right jason informed me i'm behind and i'm not hip like all the cool kids but uh i started playing pub g because it came to mobile uh ios and android and i've been playing on a tablet um so not only did jason tell me that i was behind
是的，我认为这是真正能让你与他人建立联系的事情之一。特别是你可能没有理由和苏阿姨说话，但你总是可以给苏阿姨发那个猫被困在吊扇上的视频之类的。现在我得滚动浏览所有内容了。不，我开玩笑的。说到绝对不会浪费你时间的事情，是的，对。杰森告诉我我落后了，我不像所有酷孩子那样时髦，但我开始玩PUBG，因为它来到了移动端，iOS和Android，我一直在平板电脑上玩。所以杰森不仅告诉我我落后了
the times and that he's been playing this for like literally months um but then he proceeded to tell me that the reason i am so good is because it was actually full of terrible bots and that i wasn't actually beating people i was just beating crappy bots so i was really stoked and now i'm just really sad uh so i need to stop the podcast and go back to playing. You got up to where you were playing people, right? I believe so. At least I'm getting crappier. So PUBG is Player Unknown Battlegrounds.
时代，而且他已经玩了好几个月了，然后他接着告诉我，我之所以这么厉害，是因为它实际上充满了糟糕的机器人，我并不是真的在打败人，我只是在打败垃圾机器人。所以我当时真的很兴奋，现在我真的很伤心。所以我需要停止播客回去玩。你玩到你和人对战的地方了，对吧？我想是这样。至少我变得越来越烂了。所以PUBG是《绝地求生》。
And it came out for desktop initially. And a coworker, someone on my team, actually said, hey, you should buy this game and we'll play together and i said okay so so we played it and it's just really hard and also i'm just generally not very good at at um games where you have to kind of be accurate like i don't have a lot of dexterity and so um you know i think i looked at my ranking i know granted i don't play that much i play maybe two hours a week or something. But my ranking is, like, I'm in the 70th percentile.
它最初是为桌面端推出的。我团队里的一个同事说，嘿，你应该买这个游戏，我们一起玩。我说好。所以我们玩了，它真的很难。而且我通常不太擅长需要准确性的游戏，我没有太多的灵巧度。所以我查看了我的排名，当然我玩得不多，我每周可能玩两个小时左右。但我的排名在70%左右。
And I probably, you know, probably 29% of accounts are inactive. So I'm not at all good at this game. So just for people who have never played, it's actually really cool. I was explaining it to my wife. And I mean, I'm light to the game. I had heard about it before, but I've never played it much. Or I never played it, never watched a video of it. But roughly, the idea is you and 99 other people get dropped onto an island.
我可能29%的账户是不活跃的。所以我根本不擅长这个游戏。对于那些从未玩过的人来说，它其实很酷。我当时在向我妻子解释。我的意思是，我玩这个游戏很晚。我之前听说过它，但我从来没怎么玩过。或者我从来没玩过，从来没看过它的视频。但大致上，想法是你和其他99个人被投放到一个岛上。
And it's sort of kind of like a mix of various themes you've seen before. Hunger Games, some different kinds of movies. But your goal is to survive and be the last person surviving. It doesn't take terribly long. I don't know if the computer one is the same, but on tablet, it typically takes like 25, 30 minutes maybe. Yeah, that's about the same. And so what happens is after just a couple minutes of being on the island there's going to start being a circle and you have to be inside the circle or this like energy field will come crush you when you die so
它有点像你以前见过的各种主题的混合体。《饥饿游戏》，一些不同类型的电影。但你的目标是生存，成为最后一个幸存者。这不需要太长时间。我不知道电脑版是否一样，但在平板电脑上，通常需要25、30分钟左右。是的，差不多。所以发生的事情是，在岛上待了几分钟后，就会开始出现一个圆圈，你必须在圆圈内，否则这种能量场会压碎你，当你死的时候……
basically there's an ever-closing circle that you need to stay inside of um that's compressing anyone who's staying alive down into a smaller and smaller area thereby in theory you know if there was lots of people the density would go up and they'd fight each other. But you can also collect, but you start off with nothing and you need to collect armor and weapons and ammunition and health packs. And you're running around scrambling, trying to find it. And if you come across someone, then you bad idea as opposed to other games where you know if you're playing unreal tournament or quake or one of these games you just run around shooting everything but this game you know is a lot about sound so if you shoot everyone's going to know where you are and people who are really good at the game might say oh you know if i hunt that person down i can take his
基本上有一个不断缩小的圆圈，你需要待在里面。它把所有活着的人压缩到越来越小的区域，理论上，如果人很多，密度就会增加，他们会互相战斗。但你也可以收集，你开始时什么都没有，你需要收集盔甲、武器、弹药和医疗包。你四处奔波，试图找到它。如果你遇到某人，那么……这是一个坏主意，与其他游戏不同，比如如果你在玩《虚幻竞技场》或《雷神之锤》之类的游戏，你只是四处射击所有东西。但这个游戏，你知道，很大程度上是关于声音的。所以如果你开枪，每个人都会知道你在哪里，而那些非常擅长游戏的人可能会说，哦，如果我猎杀那个人，我可以拿走他的
equipment so so not you know just letting someone run away is actually not a bad strategy right so you know running away uh knowing if you're outgunned knowing if you are going to draw someone's attention there are some vehicles you can drive around the vehicles you can hit people with your vehicles um sort of a free-for-all it i i've i've been enjoying it i don't know how long i'll stick with it because you know it's one of those things like for me it was kind of fun like goofing around and like you know doing reasonably well at um but i'm not sure i'll invest the time to sort of get amazing at it there seems to be lots of subtleties and exactly what weapons loadouts you tune for and how accurate you are and
装备。所以，不让某人跑掉其实不是一个坏策略。所以，逃跑，知道你是否火力不足，知道你是否会引起某人的注意。有一些你可以驾驶的车辆，你可以用车辆撞人。这有点像大乱斗。我一直很享受它。我不知道我会坚持多久，因为你知道，对我来说，这有点像胡闹，而且做得还不错。但我不知道我会投入时间去变得非常厉害。似乎有很多微妙之处，关于你调整什么武器配置，以及你有多准确，而且
it's also quite a bit stressful um how does the how does the shooting work on mobile i'm pretty sure it's similar it's just you use on-screen controls or whatever well because like for example when you have the sniper rifle you have to be extremely precise with the mouse to hit somebody i mean it has some amount of auto aiming on but i don't know to what extent so um i there you don't play between a computer and a mobile device so they're actually two different implementations of the game as far as i understand that makes sense right yeah you get a huge disadvantage if if you're on your phone and so or vice versa or if they have too good of auto aim then you'd be at a huge advantage oh right that's true yeah so um i'll have to try the mobile out i actually
它也相当有压力。移动端的射击是怎么运作的？我很确定它是相似的，只是你使用屏幕上的控件之类的。好吧，因为例如当你使用狙击步枪时，你必须用鼠标极其精确地击中某人。我的意思是它有一些自动瞄准功能，但我不知道程度如何。所以，你不能在电脑和移动设备之间对战，所以据我所知，它们实际上是游戏的两种不同实现。这有道理，对吧？是的，如果你在手机上，你会处于巨大的劣势，反之亦然。或者如果他们有太好的自动瞄准，那么你就会处于巨大的优势。哦，对，那是真的。所以，我得试试移动版。我其实
downloaded it but i haven't played the mobile version yet everyone probably already knows it i recommend youtube channels that have like two million subscribers and currently most popular ios games yeah you're such a rebel way to go against the grain although you told me you you literally pitched a book as it's good it was on the best seller list yeah we're just shilling the whole episode is just just an hour of us jump the shark it was popular i mean you know pub g bestseller list documentation i mean what's more popular than these things yeah and now we're going to talk about documentation the most powerful popular thing ever um documentation so um you know the first thing is and this is really true of anything is is why document and maybe we should start every
下载了它，但我还没玩过移动版。每个人可能都已经知道了，我推荐拥有两百万订阅者的YouTube频道和目前最流行的iOS游戏。是的，你真是个叛逆者，去反其道而行之。尽管你告诉我你推销了一本书，因为它很好，它在畅销书榜单上。是的，我们只是在兜售，整个节目只是我们跳过鲨鱼的一小时。它很受欢迎，我的意思是，你知道，PUBG，畅销书榜单，文档，我的意思是还有什么比这些东西更受欢迎的？是的，现在我们要谈谈文档，有史以来最流行的东西。文档，所以……你知道，第一件事，这对于任何事情都是真的，就是为什么要记录。也许我们应该从每一件事开始
language with why does this language exist we kind of do but um uh you know why document right i mean it slows you down um it you know if it's not done right you have to keep it up to date i've actually seen some pretty funny code uh we have this thing called clown town and it's just a group at work where people post just miss like like bad code and it's usually just things that have like gone south over time like rotted in a sense and there was one with someone posted and it said uh the comment said return one but i don't know why and then the next line was return zero it's like so yeah that can happen um and so you know the reason why you know we want to document and this i someone explained this to me at work you know it's about five years ago and it's just so profound it's just one of these things you don't
语言，为什么这种语言存在？我们有点这样做，但……你知道为什么要记录，对吧？我的意思是它会拖慢你的速度。如果做得不对，你必须保持它的最新状态。我其实见过一些非常有趣的评论代码。我们公司有个叫“小丑镇”的东西，这是一个工作组，人们发布糟糕的代码，通常是随着时间推移而变质的东西。有一个人发布了它，上面写着：注释说“返回1，但我不知道为什么”，然后下一行是“返回0”。所以是的，这种情况可能会发生。所以你知道，我们想要记录的原因，这是有人在五年前向我解释的，这太深刻了，这是你不会
think about is um you know if you're at a company you're almost certainly going to have some type of code review um which means like you're going to read your code because you don't want to review just you know you don't want to embarrass yourself right so you're going to go through it and then the reviewer is going to go through it um and even if you only have one reviewer and no one ever looks at it again that's already twice as many people, if you count your second pass. It's already twice as many people that have read it than written it, right? And chances are it's going to be way more than that, right? You might send a code review to two people. There might be other people on your team who look at it, right?
想到的事情。如果你在一家公司，你几乎肯定会有某种代码审查，这意味着你会阅读你的代码，因为你不想审查……你不想让自己尴尬，对吧？所以你会检查它，然后审查者会检查它。即使你只有一个审查者，而且再也没有人看它，那也已经是两倍的人数了，如果你算上你的第二次检查的话。这已经比写它的人多了一倍的人读过它，对吧？而且很有可能远不止于此，对吧？你可能会把代码审查发给两个人。你团队中可能还有其他人看它，对吧？
Also, you might come back five years later. This has happened where you come back five years later and look at something you've written. And you're basically a different person at that point because you have zero context. You're probably using this code for a different reason. And so that's yet another, you know, context that has to get filled in, right? The other part of it is you want to document to sort of let people know the intent of your code and also the span, right?
此外，你可能会在五年后回来。这种情况发生过，你五年后回来，看你写的东西。在那一点上，你基本上是一个不同的人，因为你没有任何背景。你可能因为不同的原因使用这段代码。所以这是另一个必须填补的背景，对吧？另一部分是你想要记录，以便让人们知道你代码的意图，以及范围，对吧？
So, I mean, we talked about the design interview at the beginning of the show, right? Maybe you have a function that sorts less than 100 numbers super quickly like it runs on some you know assembly code or something uh and it's just insanely fast but only sorts 100 numbers well like you need to let people know right and there are actually like um what's the term for this there are actually like programming language constructs where in the input you specify like what's expected to come in and what's expected to grow out of this function. I'm totally drawing a blank on the term for that.
所以，我的意思是，我们在节目开始时谈到了设计面试，对吧？也许你有一个函数，可以非常快地对少于100个数字进行排序，比如它运行在一些汇编代码上，它非常快，但只能对100个数字进行排序。好吧，你需要让人们知道，对吧？实际上有……这个术语是什么？实际上有编程语言结构，在输入中你指定了预期的输入和预期的输出。我完全想不起那个术语了。
But in general, most languages aren't like that. Like most languages, you know, you just say this takes an inch. You don't say this takes an inch of this to this range right um i think it's like contract yeah yeah but but you know we're not writing like that almost none of us and so the documentation is really what's going to let the person know like this is the kind of input i expect this is the kind of output i'm going to produce, right? Even just simple things like if you're in a language that has null pointers, that, like, can this be null?
但总的来说，大多数语言不是那样的。大多数语言，你只是说这需要一个整数。你不会说这需要这个范围内的整数。我想这就像契约。是的，是的，但我们不是那样写的，我们几乎没有人这样做。所以文档确实是让人们知道“这是我期望的输入，这是我将产生的输出”，对吧？即使是简单的事情，比如如果你使用的语言有空指针，这……这可以是空的吗？
Yeah, yeah, exactly. Yeah, as I expected. So, I mean, the first kind of comments talk about is sort of generic across every kind of language i guess but most at least as far as i know every language has uh is composed of source files and there's kind of and and i've had this debate back and forth with people over time like do you document large sort of uh descriptive comments at the top of a file or Or do you mostly focus on commenting, you know, sort of at the line or at the call site or at the function signature or wherever the applicable place is? Do you do both? I mean, ideally you would just document everything all the time. But, you know, it is tough sometimes because like jason was pointing out you want to document
是的，是的，完全正确。是的，正如我所料。所以，我的意思是，第一种评论谈论的是每种语言通用的，我想，但据我所知，每种语言都由源文件组成。我一直在和人们争论，你是要在文件顶部记录大型描述性注释，还是主要关注在行、调用点、函数签名或任何适用的地方进行注释？你两者都做吗？我的意思是，理想情况下，你应该一直记录所有内容。但有时这很难，因为像杰森指出的那样，你想要记录
this so when you lose the context you can come back to it but it's also hard because i think sometimes people comment the wrong things like people comment the obvious things right and not the subtle things but that's really tricky because when you're in it and the context is fresh in your head you the things you think you might need to comment are stuff that is probably easy to figure out later. And the stuff that you chose for some subtle reason, you may not think to put a comment on. But generally, I think it is good, especially for large pieces of functionality,
这个，这样当你失去背景时可以回来查看。但这也很难，因为我认为有时人们评论的是错误的事情。人们评论显而易见的事情，而不是微妙的事情。但这真的很棘手，因为当你身处其中，背景在你的脑海中很新鲜时，你认为你可能需要评论的事情，可能是以后很容易弄清楚的事情。而你出于某种微妙原因选择的事情，你可能不会想到要加注释。但总的来说，我认为这很好，特别是对于大型功能，
to have a bunch of comments up at the top that sort of says what the point of the file is, what the direction you're going in maybe some use cases and that's going to force you to organize your file system it's going to force you to organize your source files in some meaningful way yeah i mean i'm a big fan of like documentation at all levels if that makes sense like your organization of your code should be somewhat documentation like what files are in what folders for instance um to me or in what modules is like a form of documentation like have a logical layout so that if someone's like i wonder where this thing lives they have a reasonable chance of finding it on the first try i've been in code bases before where
在顶部有一堆注释，说明文件的目的是什么，你的方向是什么，也许还有一些用例。这将迫使你组织你的文件系统，迫使你以某种有意义的方式组织你的源文件。是的，我的意思是，我是各级文档的忠实拥护者，如果这有意义的话。你的代码组织应该在某种程度上像文档，例如哪些文件在哪些文件夹中。对我来说，或者在哪些模块中，是一种文档形式。拥有一个逻辑布局，这样如果有人想“我想知道这个东西住在哪里”，他们有合理的几率在第一次尝试时找到它。我以前在代码库中遇到过
things just are all over the place. They don't make sense or just one gigantic folder. I don't care for that as much because I feel like it's documentation in depth. That's what I'm going to say. Yes. Yeah. I think too, another part of it is it's a living system in a sense, because there's just constantly people modifying it. And usually when you see, for example, as Patrick mentioned, a directory with 200 source files in it, nobody really set out to say, I want this to be the one directory to rule them all.
东西到处都是。它们没有意义，或者只是一个巨大的文件夹。我不太喜欢那样，因为我觉得这是深度的文档。这就是我要说的。是的。是的。我也认为，另一个部分是它在某种意义上是一个活的系统，因为不断有人在修改它。通常当你看到，正如帕特里克提到的，一个包含200个源文件的目录时，没有人真正打算说“我希望这是统治所有人的目录”。
What happened is someone started with one file and then two files and then 10 files, and nobody really stepped in and said, okay, I'm going to take a month to sort of break this up into 10 different directories or something. And so, you know, it's going to require like constant effort. And that gets back to the downside of commenting, which is, you know, you have to maintain that. But, you know, the upsides are well worth it. Yeah. I mean, I don't think anyone's going to
发生的事情是有人从一个文件开始，然后是两个文件，然后是10个文件，没有人真正介入说“好吧，我要花一个月时间把它拆分成10个不同的目录”。所以，你知道，它需要持续的努力。这又回到了评论的缺点，即你必须维护它。但好处是完全值得的。是的，我的意思是，我不认为有人会
disagree. Some documentation is good, but finding the balance is, can be tricky. Cause I find sometimes you get really long comments that are, you end up skipping because it's just like, oh man, this person like this. Yes. I know you're just looping over all the things in the list. Yeah.
不同意。一些文档是好的，但找到平衡点可能很棘手。因为我发现有时你会得到非常长的评论，你最终会跳过它们，因为这就像，“哦，伙计，这个人喜欢这个。”是的。我知道你只是在循环遍历列表中的所有内容。是的。
Yeah. I got it. Yeah, exactly. Yep. Um, so yeah, I think there's also ways to sort of self document.
是的。我明白了。是的，完全正确。是的。所以，是的，我认为还有一些自我记录的方法。
Um, you know, I think, I think, as Patrick mentioned, you can do the document at the top of the file. You could do documents in the functions, documents within the code, things like that. And the nice thing about those is, and we'll talk about these later, is there's something called generators that will kind of basically create a manual of your source code automatically. But in addition to doing that, something else that's basically free and, you know, it'll save you from having errors in the future. So it's kind of a no-brainer is to basically write self-documenting code. And so example of this and we'll kind of trade off different examples is you know and they always talk about one of the biggest problems challenges in software engineering is naming things right and so it's kind of like a tongue-in-cheek thing to say but there's a lot of
嗯，你知道，我想，正如帕特里克提到的，你可以在文件顶部写文档。你可以在函数里写文档，在代码里写文档，诸如此类。这些文档的好处是——我们稍后会讨论——有一种叫做生成器的东西，可以自动为你创建源代码手册。但除了这些，还有一些基本上是免费的，而且你知道，它能让你在未来避免出错。所以，编写自解释代码（self-documenting code）基本上是不言而喻的。举个例子，我们会轮流举例，你知道，人们总是说软件工程中最大的挑战之一就是命名，对吧？所以这听起来有点像俏皮话，但其中有很多
truth to that I think you know picking variable names and function names um is super super important i've noticed over time especially now that i've gotten good with you know emacs emac key bindings in whatever editor i'm using i have pretty long variable names and i find that that really helps a lot. So, for example, the other day I had something where it was a data structure that was a list of models. And then each model was a list of examples. And then each example had a list of features. And so I had a variable called top, or I think it was like root or something like that. And then I was interested in the first model. So I create another variable that was called, you know, examples, underscore four, underscore model, underscore zero. And it was equal root, you know,
道理，我认为，你知道，选择变量名和函数名，嗯，非常非常重要。我随着时间的推移注意到，特别是现在我已经熟练掌握了 Emacs 键绑定，无论我使用什么编辑器，我都会使用很长的变量名，我发现这真的很有帮助。例如，前几天我有一个数据结构，是一个模型列表。然后每个模型是一个示例列表。然后每个示例都有一个特征列表。所以我有一个变量叫 top，或者我想是 root 之类的。然后我想要第一个模型。所以我创建了另一个变量，叫 examples_for_model_zero。它等于 root，你知道，
index zero. This is like a huge variable name, but it tells someone exactly, you know, what that data is representing. And if you're using something like JavaScript with ES6 or C++ or something where you could do const, that's even better, right? Because now that variable is only ever going to represent that thing and people know it. In my case, I'm doing Python, so I don't really have const. But kind of style and and doing that with functions as well really helps and it could probably save you from writing a line of documentation there i mean i think anytime you have variables and are able to use them like like jason was pointing out rather than just indexing in now obviously you could take it to an extreme but providing extra context for something breaking up stuff into different
索引零。这就像一个巨大的变量名，但它准确地告诉了别人，你知道，那个数据代表什么。如果你使用像 ES6 的 JavaScript 或 C++ 这样可以使用 const 的语言，那就更好了，对吧？因为现在那个变量将永远只代表那个东西，人们也都知道。就我而言，我用的是 Python，所以我没有真正的 const。但这种风格，以及在函数中也这样做，真的很有帮助，它可能让你省去写一行文档的麻烦。我的意思是，我认为任何时候你有变量，并且能够像杰森指出的那样使用它们，而不是仅仅进行索引，显然你可以走极端，但提供额外的上下文，把东西拆分成不同的
function oh that's a lot of stuff breaking up things into different functions and saying hey i'm gonna put a function here not because i need to but because it makes it cleaner to read um and anytime you can limit the number of variables, any piece of code you have to sort of think about to be able to execute, that's also going to be an advantage. Although we just said to make new variables. Um, but I mean, the keeping variables that are related around are good, but if you have code that just sort of becomes really long and there's lots and lots of variables in play, that also becomes difficult to read. definitely i think you know one thing i do when i'm doing c++ coding um and tell me if you do this patrick is is uh i tend to put a lot
函数——哦，那有很多东西——把东西拆分成不同的函数，说“嘿，我要在这里放一个函数，不是因为我需要，而是因为它读起来更清晰”。嗯，任何时候你都能限制变量的数量，任何你需要思考才能执行的代码片段，那也将是一个优势。虽然我们刚才说要创建新变量。嗯，但我的意思是，保持相关的变量在一起是好的，但如果你的代码变得非常长，并且有很多很多变量在起作用，那也会变得难以阅读。绝对的，我想，你知道，我做 C++ 编码时做的一件事，嗯，告诉我你是否也这样做，帕特里克，就是我倾向于放很多
of extra braces like it's not the braces aren't connected to an if or a for or anything like that but it's like i have a set of and maybe these are things that really should be functions, but I have some variable that I know is just going to live for a few lines of this function. So I just put braces to let people know, look, this variable dies right away. And so don't expect it to be around the rest of the function. And that kind of helps people modularize it. I feel like there's a trade-off, like you could just have a lot of functions and let the, you know, let the function, you know,
额外的花括号，就像这些花括号不与 if 或 for 或任何类似的东西连接，但就像我有一组——也许这些东西真的应该是函数，但我有一些变量，我知道它只会在这个函数的几行代码中存活。所以我只是加上花括号让人们知道，看，这个变量马上就失效了。所以不要指望它在函数的其余部分还存在。这有助于人们模块化它。我觉得这是一种权衡，就像你可以有很多函数，让函数定义所有的作用域等等。但在某种程度上，这实际上可能变得有点难以阅读，因为你最终会有很多函数散落在各处。你必须小心，比如你如何对它们进行排序等等，所以它还是相当可读的。嗯，所以我发现，特别是对于小事情，比如少于 10 行的代码，与其为此创建一个函数，我不如把变量包在花括号里，这样你知道 C++ 会销毁它，虽然这本身并没有什么用，但它确实只是让人们知道这个变量有一个非常小的上下文。我的意思是，我以前见过这种情况。
define all the scope and all of that. But at some point that actually can get kind of hard to read because you end up with a lot of functions kind of scattered all over the place. And you have to be careful, like how you sort of order them and things like that so it's so it's pretty readable um so i've found that for particularly like for small things let's say like less than 10 lines um instead of making a function for that i'll just wrap the variables in braces so that you know c++ kind of destroys it which that's not really that useful per se but it's really just that people know that this variable has a very small, you know, context. I mean, I have seen that before.
我不太倾向于使用你说的这种确切模式。我的意思是，在某些情况下，比如标准锁，或者如果我知道，如果我有一个昂贵的分配，我需要做你说的完全一样的事情。我认为人们可以使用，我不记得那叫什么了。没有 if 或 for 循环之类的花括号，只是空的空部分或部分。是的，我想它只是被称为作用域，但我不知道。好的，是的。所以使用作用域可能可以达到更好的效果。
I don't tend to do the exact pattern you're saying. I mean, there are certain cases with like standard locks or if I know, if I have an expensive allocation where I need to do exactly what you're saying. I think people could use the, I don't remember what that's called. The curly braces without if or for loop or whatever, just the empty empty sections or the sections. Yeah, I think it's just called a scope, but I don't know. OK, yeah. So like using scopes probably could use it to better effect.
但我认为你也不想做得太过火。是的，它不是一个标准的东西，你知道，所以是的。但我的意思是，我认为所有这些都是为了说明，你要在命名时小心谨慎，并利用语言的特性来发挥你的优势，并试图帮助它使其具有描述性。但我们也指出，类型是一种文档形式，尽管杰森也说他在用 Python 工作。其实，嘿，嘿，嘿，Python，我不知道你知不知道，但我们使用 Python 3，我们在所有东西上都使用类型。哦，所有东西。
But I mean, I think you also don't want to go overboard. Yeah, like it isn't a standard thing and you know so yeah but i mean i think all this stuff is to say that you try to be careful in what you name things and use the features of the language to your advantage and in trying to help it make it descriptive but we've also pointed out that types are a form of documentation, despite Jason also said that he was working in Python. Actually, hey, hey, hey, Python, I don't know if you know this, but we use Python 3 and we use types on everything. Oh, everything.
是的，所以 Python 3 有 typing。你可以导入 typing，然后说，你知道，实际上你从 typing 导入 dict 和 list 以及所有这些类型，对吧？然后我们实际上有一个类型检查器，我想它用的是 mypy，但嗯，但是的，我的意思是，你知道，没有像，呃，呃，怎么说，像强制规定之类的，比如“哦，你没在这里放类型，你被解雇了”，但就像，你知道，如果有人写了整个文件，例如没有类型，那么他们可能会得到一些反馈，比如“嘿，你知道，你应该在这里放类型”。不错，那很好。是的，是的，类型非常非常重要，没有类型简直就是一场噩梦。
Yeah, so Python 3 has a typing. You can import typing and then say like you know actually you do from typing import you know dict and list and all those types right and uh and then we actually have a type checker i think it uses my pi but um but yeah i mean you know it's there's not like a uh uh what's the word like a mandate or something it's like oh you didn't put a type here you're fired but it's like uh you know if if someone writes a whole file for example with no types then they'll probably get some feedback like hey you know you should you should put types here nice that's good yeah yeah the types are super super important without types it's just a night
其实帕特里克和我在同一家公司工作时，我们写了很多没有类型的 Python，那真的很痛苦。杰森写了很多，不，我开玩笑的。是的，你是对的。我知道很多人真的很喜欢没有类型的东西。我们可以深入讨论那个。让我们留到以后的讨论中吧。
actually patrick and i at the time we worked at the same company and we wrote a bunch of Python without types and that was pretty rough. Jason wrote a bunch of, no, I'm just kidding. Yeah, you're right. I know a lot of people really like stuff without types. We can get into that. Let's save this for a different discussion.
让我们继续。当然。所以生成器。生成器的想法是在你的代码中编写注释或带有特殊标记的注释，然后将其导出到网页、PDF 或其他形式，从而总结你的代码，而不包含代码本身。是的，如果你曾经见过这个，你可能见过，你可以分辨出来，因为它有点——不是为了贬低它——它看起来有点傻，因为你知道这些生成器
Let's keep going. Sure. So generators. So the idea of a generator is writing comments or specially tagged comments in your code that then gets exported to a web's page or a pdf or a different form that sort of summarizes your code without containing your code itself yep and you've probably seen this if you've ever um seen like you can tell because it kind of not to not to start off by disparaging it but it kind of looks goofy because you know these these generators
它们不需要根据你的代码可能产生的任何东西来设计它们的外观，对吧？所以如果你见过这种奇怪的四面板类型的网站，左上角面板有所有的 Java 命名空间，左下角有类，然后我想是三面板。然后在右边，你有你当前正在查看的任何类。当你看到它时你就会知道。它们看起来都差不多。很少有人真正更改默认主题的默认模板。但是的，那是自动生成的东西。
they don't they have to design the way they look on based on anything that could come out of your code, right? And so if you've seen this weird sort of four-panel type website where you have all the Java namespaces in the top left panel, the classes in the bottom left, and then I guess it's three-panel. And then on the right, you have whatever class you're looking at at the moment. And you'll know it when you see it. It's like they all kind of look the same. Very few people actually change a default template for the default theme. But yeah, that's something that was auto-generated.
所以那些人不必创建那个网站或任何东西。他们只需要运行这些生成器之一，网站就出来了。他们只需要把它放在某个服务平台上。所以我先说一下，我实际上作为一个整体不喜欢代码生成器。我倾向于不使用它们。你是在说文档生成器还是通用的代码生成器？哦不，我明白了，是的，文档生成器。好的，是的，是的，比如 Java docs。如果我在写 Java，我从来不喜欢，我不喜欢去读 Java docs，我觉得它们没有价值。我们有一些带有 Doxygen 注释的代码，我从来不生成 Doxygen 去看它。我
And so those people don't have to create that website or anything. They just run one of these generators and a website comes out. They just have to put it on a serving platform somewhere so i'm gonna start this off by saying i actually dislike code generators as a whole i tend to not use them and you talk about like the document generators or just code generators in general oh no i get yeah document generators okay yeah yeah like java docs if i'm writing java i never like i dislike going and reading java docs i don't find them valuable i i don't we have some pieces of code that have doxygen comments on them i never generate the doxygen and go look at it i don't
不知道，你不认为其他人会看吗，比如其他团队什么的？我不看，我很害怕，我是个怀疑论者，我等着被说服。我认为它们有它们的位置，而且我认为如果说不出别的，我认为它们对于强制执行注释风格非常有用，比如你应该注释你的返回类型是什么，你应该注释，你知道，每个公共函数，例如，应该有一些注释说明它做了什么。但我不是，问题是很多时候当你试图让它们非常丰富时，它们实际上在代码中变得不那么可读了。所以我感觉人们最终陷入了这种二分法：要么让生成的文档好而代码坏，要么让代码的可读性更好而文档坏。这是一个非常有趣的观点，比如我会给你
know you don't think other people do like other teams or whatever i don't i'm scared i'm a skeptic i'm waiting to be convinced i think they have their place and i think if if nothing else i mean i think they're really useful for sort of enforcing a style to comments like you should comment on what your return type is you should comment you know what that each fun each you know public function for example should have some comment on it that says what it does um but i'm not like the problem is a lot of times when you try to make them very rich they actually become less readable in the code and so i feel people end up in this dichotomy of either making the generated docs good and the code bad or the readableness and the code better and the docs bad that's a really interesting point like i'll give
一个具体的例子，我在这一点上同意你的看法，那就是参数。所以如果你想做，你知道，如果你想在 Python 中支持 Sphinx，这是 Python 中的代码生成器之一，如果你输入 @param，无论参数名称是什么，所以如果你有一个参数名称叫 number of places，你输入 @number of places，冒号，或者我想是 @param 空格 number of places 空格，然后是该参数的描述。如果你这样做，它看起来确实很好。它的输出，比如在你运行 Sphinx 并查看生成的网页后，它确实很好，你可以把鼠标悬停在参数上
you a specific example where i agree with you on that is the parameters so if you if you want to do you know the if you want to support sphinx in python which is one of the code generators in Python, if you put at param, whatever the parameter name is, so if you have a parameter name like number of places, you do at number of places, colon, or I think it's at param space number of places space, and then a description of what that parameter is. And if you do that, it looks really nice. The output of that, like after you run Sphinx and you look at the web pages generated, it's really nice and you can hover over the parameter
它会以工具提示的形式读给你听，对吧？但实际的文档看起来很丑。它会随机出现 @ 符号。而且，人们开始解释那些不需要解释的参数。是的，就像你知道，我知道那个参数是什么意思，你知道。是的，这就是对我来说的问题，不仅仅是文档变得有点困难，特别是当人们开始使用超链接之类的东西时，是的，我不喜欢它，它变得非常混乱。所以在你的代码中有一个超链接是可以的，但是
and it reads it to you in like a tool tip, right? But the actual documentation looks ugly. It gives you at signs randomly. And plus, people start explaining parameters that don't need to be explained yes it's like you know i i know what that parameter means you know yeah that's the thing for me is like not only does like the documentation become sort of a little difficult and especially when people start using hyperlinks and stuff and yeah i don't like it just becomes really messy so having a hyperlink in your code is okay but
然后把它标记出来并正确标记，以便它在文档中看起来很好，这变得非常繁琐。但正如杰森指出的，很多时候，这对于文档作为一个整体主题来说是真实的，那就是理解有些东西并不总是需要被记录。所以像，你知道，我试着想一个好的例子，比如这里有一个例子，假设你有一个数组，你知道，模型，一个叫 models 的数组，他们有一个变量叫 number of models，因为你在 C++ 中做这个。是的，当然。是的，是的，你真的写了一个注释“number of models 是 number of models”。是的，完全正确，是的。
then having it flagged out and tagged properly so that it gets you know looks good in the documentation just becomes very cumbersome but as jason pointed out a lot of times which is true of documentation just as a whole topic is like understanding some things don't always need to be documented and so something like you know i'm trying to think of a good example it's like one of the things here's an example let's let's say you have an array of you know model an array called models and they have a variable called number of models because you're doing this in c++ yeah sure yeah yeah and you really write a comment number of models is number of models yeah Yeah, exactly, yeah.
或者一个叫 getIndex 的函数，它接收一个叫 i 的变量，然后你说“i 是要获取的索引”，是的，呃。是的，是的，回到帕特里克的观点，就像，你知道，当你使用生成器时，它真的迫使你必须解释那些可能无关紧要的事情。而且，你知道，这意味着人们会对你的注释变得有点麻木。因为如果一半的注释都不重要，他们就不会太注意另一半。我想我也有这种担心，那就是
Or a function called getIndex, and it takes in a variable called i, and you say i is the index of which to get the, yeah, ugh. Yeah, and yeah, to Patrick's point, like, you know, when you use a generator, it really compels you to have to explain things that probably don't matter. And, you know, what that means is people will get a little bit more deaf to your comments. Because if half the comments don't matter, they're going to pay less attention to the other half. I guess I also have this worry that there's
人们会花一定的时间在文档上，我希望他们把时间花在最重要的事情上。如果他们把时间花在，你知道，清理他们每个不重要的参数名称的格式和间距上，他们就没有把时间花在以一种更可读、更易维护的方式重构代码上。是的。但在另一方面，如果你看真正的核心库，
a sort of a amount of time people will spend documenting and I want them to spend it on the stuff that matters most. And if they're spending it on, you know, cleaning up the formatting and spacing of every one of their parameter names that don't matter, they're not spending it in like restructuring the code in just a more readable, maintainable way. Yeah. On the flip side though, like if you look at really core libraries,
你知道，他们非常充分地利用了这一点。这就是，你知道，像 tensorflow 这样的库，或者例如像 tensorflow，有很多人在使用它，他们在某种意义上是在冒险，因为你知道，他们在使用 tensorflow 而不是构建自己的东西，如果事实证明他们需要以某种方式扩展 tensorflow，他们真的指望那里有一种社会契约。而且，如果你没有生成器，人们很难上手，你知道，只是潜入代码中。所以我真的没有——这将是一个奇怪的节目，因为我们并没有真正的灵丹妙药。嗯，你知道，也许这是一个让某人发明一些完全新颖的东西的机会。
you know, they make tremendous use of this. And this is like, you know, library tremendous use of this and this is like you know library like tensorflow or for example like tensorflow there's so many people using it they're in a sense taking a risk because you know they're using tensorflow instead of building their own thing and if it turns out they need to extend tensorflow in some way they're really counting on there's like a social contract there and uh if you don't have the generator it's it's kind of hard for people to get started you know just diving in through the code so i don't really have this is going to be a weird show in the sense that we don't really have a silver bullet um you know maybe this is an opportunity for someone to like invent something totally novel
但，你知道，是的，我同意帕特里克的观点，生成器确实导致人们写出非常奇怪的注释，而且结构不是很好。另一方面，如果人们使用生成器但只写重要的注释，那么生成的输出看起来就不太好。它不完整，是的。是的，因为生成器会做的是它会打印你所有的函数，但随后你大部分的函数看起来会非常空，看起来会非常怪异。
but uh you know yeah i agree with patrick that the generators kind of cause people to write very odd comments and not very well structured comments on the flip side if people um use the generators but write only the important comments then the generated output doesn't look very good. It's not complete, yeah. Yeah, because what the generator will do is it will print all of your functions, but then the majority of your functions will look very bare and it'll look very bizarre.
总的来说，这是生成器的一个问题，你可能会有，比如假设你有一个辅助函数，sort array 之类的。它只是在帮助你的类做某事。也许它甚至是私有的。生成器，现在有规则，或者也许它们不会生成文档
In general, that's a problem with generators where you might have, like let's say you have a helper function, sort array or something like that. And it's just helping your class do something. Maybe it's even private. The generators, now there are rules or maybe they won't generate docs
关于私有函数之类的东西。但你仍然会遇到一些情况，即无关紧要的东西基本上会出现在文档中。比如很多函数可能对 99% 的受众来说都不重要。所以所有这些，是的，我想，你知道，也许生成器，但需要很多手把手的指导可能是可行的方法。但你刚才提到了一个很好的观点，说像这其中的一部分是，
on private functions and things like that. But you're still gonna encounter cases where things are basically gonna show up in the documentation that don't matter. Like a lot of the functions probably don't matter to 99% of your audience. And so all of that, yeah, I think, you know, maybe generators, but with a lot of handholding could be the way to go. But you brought up a really good point though a minute ago about saying like part of this is,
你现在正在详细阐述它，这其中的一部分是有多少人会使用你的代码。如果你正在编写一些深层的内部东西，这些东西并不会真正被很多人共享，那么文档很重要，但像发布到网站上可能就不那么重要了。但像，你知道，tensorflow 或其他将成为通用工具的东西，那么它可能值得投资，对吧？并花费维护它的持续成本。这是一个很难平衡的问题，因为我认为很多时候我们之前谈到过，这是有机增长的，你不会想“哦，这段代码会被所有人使用”，然后它确实被使用了。我想这是一个甜蜜的烦恼，但，你知道，或者你可能会想“哦天哪，这么多人会想用这个，快花这么多时间
and you're sort of elaborating on it now like part of this is how many people are going to be using your code if you're writing some like deep internal something that isn't really going to be shared by a lot of people um then the kind documentation is important but the kind of like put it out to a website maybe less so but something like you know tensorflow or something that's going to be a common utility then it's it might be worth investing in right and spending the ongoing cost of maintaining that's a hard balance to strike because i think a lot of times we were talking about before this grows organically you don't think like oh this code is going to be used by everyone uh and and then it is i guess that's a good problem to have but uh you know or you could think oh man so many people are going to want to use this come and spend so much time
记录它”，然后你知道，它从来没有被使用过。是的，那是，那是，是的，你想在这里做惰性求值，你想让你的项目变得超级流行，然后把它记录为一个超级流行的项目。但这也很难做到。是的，我的意思是，好吧，我会把它放在你的盘子里。假设你继承了一些项目，比如你继承了 Firefox，代码库。哦，亲爱的。
documenting it and then you know it never is yeah that's that's yeah you want to do lazy evaluation here like you want you want your project to get uber popular and then to document it as an uber popular project. But that's tough to do too. Yeah, I mean, well, I'll put it on your plate. Let's say you inherited some project that had, like you inherited Firefox, the code base. Oh, dear.
它有，你知道，也许它有一些内联文档，你会如何记录这样的东西？什么是最好的？这很难，但我的意思是，像 Firefox 是一个很好的例子，它有很多很多人，我不知道 Firefox 的具体细节，但很多人使用 Firefox，但大多数人并不把它当作 SDK 使用。所以，好观点，像什么，他们的 JavaScript 引擎叫什么？我忘了，嗯，但是，嗯，Gecko 还是什么？是那个吗？哦不，不，Spider Monkey。是的，是的，Spider Monkey。好的，那我就相信你了。Spider Monkey，就像他可能需要比字体渲染器更好的文档。是的，这说得通。我正在学习。
And it has, you know, maybe it has some inline doc like how would you document something like that like what would what would be the best it's tough but i mean like you're like firefox is a good example it's like lots of people and i don't i have no idea about specifics of firefox but lots of people use firefox but most people don't use it as like an sdk so the kind of good point the kinds of things like what is their uh javascript engine called i forgot now um but um gecko or something is that oh no no uh spider monkey yeah yeah spider monkey okay so i'll take your word. Spider monkey, like he probably needs better documentation than like the font renderer. Yeah, that makes sense. I'm picking stuff up.
但对，就像试图理解，作为一个整体，Firefox 可能不需要同等的文档。所以我猜这和我们在文件中谈论的是一样的。它是递归的。哦，亲爱的。递归，哦，亲爱的。嗯，所以是的，也许如果我必须在这里想出一个策略，我会说如果你正在编写一些开始吸引广泛开发者基础的东西，比如，假设超过 500 名开发者，或者你正在构建一个 SDK，目标是拥有成千上万的开发者，那么这是唯一最重要的目标，那么走这条生成器路线，花时间和精力去做所有的人工策划和东西，
But right, like trying to understand like as a whole, Firefox probably doesn't need equal documentation. So I guess it's the same thing like we were talking about in the files. It's recursive. Oh, dear. recursive oh dear um so yeah maybe if i had to come up with a strategy here i would say if you're writing something that starts to attract a broad brace a broad base of developers like let's say more than 500 developers or something like that or you're building an sdk where the goal is to have thousands of developers like that is the sole most important goal then uh go this generator route and take the time and effort to do all the manual curation and and stuff like
这样你就剔除了所有无意义的东西，你记录了所有重要的事情。但对于你系统中的其他部分或你工作的其他任何事情，是的，跳过生成器，自己写注释，你知道，函数之类的。我确实要说，我用过的很多生成器，Java docs 相当不错，因为我觉得如果你只是以一种最小侵入性的方式使用它们，它们非常有帮助，即使你从来没有生成过文档。我，我不认为我曾经生成过 Java docs 的输出，我不知道，我甚至不知道该怎么做，其实，所以我很确定我以前从来没做过。嗯，我做过 Doxygen 和 Sphinx，我们有 njs docs，所以我从来没做过 Java docs。我只见过它们，但我会说，我读过源代码中大量的 Java doc 注释，而且在大多数情况下，当人们有点
that so that it it you've pruned out all the meaningless stuff and you you um you document everything for the stuff that matters but then for every other part of your system or for every other thing you work on, yeah, just skip the generator and do the comments, you know, kind of yourself and the function and all that. I will say actually a lot of the ones I've used, Java docs are pretty good because I feel that if you use them just in the minimally intrusive way they're pretty helpful and even if you never generate the docs like i i don't think i've ever generated java docs the output i don't know i don't even know i wouldn't even know how to do it actually so i'm pretty sure i've never done it before um i've done doxygen and sphinx we have njs docs so i've never done java docs either i've only seen them but i will say that i have read lots of java doc comments in source code and that for the most part that when someone people go kind
有点疯狂过头时，我认为他们确实达到了一个不错的平衡。你可以把它当作一种稍微结构化一点的注释。是的，然后这只是一个附带的好处，如果你这样做，你可能会得到这些生成的文档。是的，其实我们应该解释一下。所以这些生成器在底层的工作方式是，嗯，你知道，在生成器文档中，它们会解释，你知道，具体你需要如何记录，无论是函数、类，还是文件顶部、模块（在 Python 中是这样称呼的），或者变量名，等等。它会告诉你，看，如果你想记录这个函数的这个参数，这正是你需要写的。它通常是一些前言文本之类的东西。这会让生成器知道你即将要说的内容的上下文。然后你写你的注释。也许它是基于换行符或基于两个换行符之类的。这就是它知道如何到达结尾的方式。然后生成器所做的是它会递归地解析你所有的源代码，提取所有这些相关的注释以及它所涉及的代码。它通常只是基于紧跟在注释后面的代码，然后它会生成，它可以生成很多东西，HTML，它可以生成 PDF。这些生成器之一可以生成所有这些不同的格式。
of sort of crazy overboard i think they they do strike a decent balance like you can use it as a sort of slightly more structured comment yeah and then it's just sort of this side benefit that it also happens that if you do that you could get this generated documents yeah actually we should explain that a little bit so so the way these generators actually work under the hood is um you know in the generator documentation they're going to explain you know specifically how you need to document, whether it's a function, a class, whether it's the top of the file, a module, in the case is what it's called in Python, or a variable name, so on and so forth. It's going to tell you, look, if you want to document this parameter of this
所以你可以字面上得到一个包含所有这些文档的 PDF，打印出来给某人，说，这是我的代码手册。所以从这个意义上说，它真的很酷。但正如我们所谈到的，它必须完成。自动生成的东西并不那么优雅。是的，所以从这个意义上说，它真的很酷。但正如我们所谈到的，它必须完成，你知道，自动生成的东西并不，你知道，那么优雅。你仍然需要做一些手把手的指导。
function, this is exactly what you need to write. It's usually some preamble text or something like that. And that's going to let the generator know the context of what you're about to say. And then you write your comment. And maybe it's based on a line break or based on two line breaks or something like that. That's how it knows to reach the end of that. And then what the generator does is it will recursively parse through all of your source code pull out all of those relevant comments and the code that it pertains to it's usually just based on the code that is immediately following the comment and then it will it will generate and it can generate a lot of things html it could generate a p a PDF. One of these generators could generate all of these different formats.
你有没有，我其实，我为我的博士代码使用了 Doxygen。所以我的博士项目，就像，相对受欢迎。我不知道。让我查一下。哦，亲爱的。是的，现在它可能……我会感觉很糟糕。不，不要以让我感觉糟糕来结束这个。好吧，这就像多年来的工作，没有报酬。
And so you could literally just get a PDF with all of this documentation and print it out and give it to somebody and say, here's the manual of my code. So in that sense, it's really cool. But as we talked about, it has to be done. The auto-generated stuff isn't that elegant. Yeah, so in that sense, it's really cool. But as we talked about, it has to be done, you know, the auto-generated stuff isn't, you know, that elegant. You still have to do some hand-holding.
所以你根本不应该为此感到糟糕。是的，我为此使用了 Doxygen。我觉得它相当合理。我敢打赌可能没人看过它。但它做的一件事是它有点强制你，给你一些压力去记录一切，因为当你生成这个文档时，一半的东西是空的，这看起来很奇怪。在你查那个的时候，我的意思是，我认为文档通常是那种每个人都觉得我们可以做得更好的事情。而且我不知道有没有人……
Have you, I've actually, I used Doxygen for my PhD code. So my PhD project was, like, relatively popular. I don't know. Let me look it up. Oh, dear. Yeah, now it's probably... I'm going to feel bad. No, don't end this with me feeling bad. Well, this is like years and years of work with no pay.
我不认为有一个确切的最佳平衡点。所以要务实，但要写文档。不要成为团队中那个说“没有文档，我的代码很棒，不需要文档”的家伙。是的。另一件事是很多人没有，那个词怎么说？好的。很多人没有，如果你在运行 shell 命令，你可能不会把它放到一个文件中，你应该这样做。所以，很多人没有，如果你在运行一堆 shell 命令，你可能不会把它放到一个文件中。你应该这样做。所以换句话说，我注意到的最大的文档失礼实际上是——也许这只是特定的，你知道，我所做的编程类型的本质。但我看到的最大错误不是人们不记录函数之类的东西。而是有人有这种，这种“哦，我运行这个，我运行这个命令，我运行这个命令”，最终字面上就像可能是 10 个命令，他们每次都把它们全部输入。不要那样做。就像，即使它只是一个命令，也要写一个 bash 脚本，记录 bash 脚本并把它放在仓库里。所以你会注意到，如果你去 eternal terminal 仓库，我有一堆 bash 脚本，它们只是一行代码，甚至没那么复杂，但这些一行 bash 脚本太容易忘记了。
So you should not feel bad at all about this. Yeah, and I used Doxygen for that. And i felt like it was it was pretty reasonable i i want to bet probably nobody looked at it um but uh it kind of one thing it does is it kind of enforces you put some pressure on you to document everything because it looks weird when you generate this document and half the stuff's empty while you're looking that up i mean i think documentation in general is one of those things you generate this document and half the stuff's empty. While you're looking that up, I mean, I think documentation in general is one of those things that everybody feels we could do better at. And I don't know that anyone...
确实。当涉及到 shell 时，记录 shell 和流程实际上非常重要。好了，伙计。但是的，我想总结一下，它是一个活的东西。不要指望有什么灵丹妙药。帕特里克和我，我们两个，我们一直在软件行业。我的意思是，加起来很多年了，太多年了，其实前几天，嗯，无论如何，我要改变这个，但是的，我们已经
I don't think there's exactly a clear best balance of it. So be practical, but do write documents. Don't be the guy or gal on the team that says, no documents, my code is amazing. It doesn't need documentation. Yeah. Another thing is a lot of people don't, what's the word for this? Okay. A lot of people don't, if you're running a shell commands, you might not put that into a file and you should do that. So, a lot of people don't, if you're running a bunch of shell commands, you might not put that into a file. And you should do that. So in other words, the biggest documentation faux pas I've noticed is actually and maybe it's just the nature of the particular, you know, type of
做了很长时间了，尴尬的长，而且，嗯，我们在这里真的没有灵丹妙药。嗯，你知道，总的来说，像这样的任何事情，只是要保持领先。所以就我个人而言，我在 Now at Work 所做的事情，我在文档方面绝对放松了。这是一件不太受欢迎的事情，现在它变得越来越受欢迎了。所以现在是时候说，好吧，我要花一周时间，我要真正清理文档。而这实际上会迫使我也清理代码。比如把代码组织成不同的，你知道，组织
programming I do. But the biggest mistake I see is not people not documenting the functions and things like that. But it's somebody has like this, this oh i run this and i run this command i run this command ends up being like literally like could be 10 commands and they just type them all in every time don't do that like like even if it's just one command make a bash script document the bash script and put it in the repository um so you'll notice if you go to the eternal terminal repo, I have a bunch of bash scripts that are just one-liners and they're not even that complicated, but it's just so easy to forget these one-line bash scripts.
文件之类的。所以就这样对待它，你知道。与其试图提前找到完美的计划，你知道，向后看而不是向前看。看看事情进展如何，然后不断适应。好的，好的，非常感谢你支持这个节目，通过 Patreon、Audible，也通过你的电子邮件。这实际上是一个推荐，但这是一个来自
Indeed. When it comes to shell, documenting shell and the flow is actually really important. All right, man. But yeah, I guess to conclude it, it's a living thing. Don't expect to have some silver bullet. Patrick and I, between the two of us, we've been in software. I mean, combined a lot of years too many years actually the other day uh anyway i'm going to change on this but yeah we've been
一年多前的推荐，嗯，我只是在浏览，你知道，旧邮件，你知道，专门寻找节目主题。我看到了这个。我想，哦，这是一个很棒的主题。它真的可以吸引任何人。所以我老实说没有跟踪是谁告诉我的，但无论谁建议了这个，谢谢。对于那些给我们发电子邮件的人，你知道，在 Twitter、Facebook 上回复我们，等等，非常感谢你的反馈。而且经济上显然很好，让服务器运行，让灯光运行，让我们买麦克风之类的东西，这样我们就可以接触到更多的人。所以，嗯，非常感谢，我们下个月见。片头音乐是 Binar Pilot 的 Axo。
doing this for a long time embarrassingly long time and uh we don't really have a silver bullet here um you know in general the the like with anything like this it's just to stay on top of it. So personally, the stuff I'm doing at Now at Work, I've definitely gone loose on the documentation. It's something that wasn't very popular, and now it's becoming more popular. And so now it's time to say, okay, I'm going to take a week, and I'm going to just really clean up the documentation. And what that will do is it will actually force me to clean the code as well. Like organize the code into different, you know, organize
programming throwdown 是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，以重新混合、改编作品，但你必须提供对帕特里克和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
the files and things like that. And so just treat it like that, you know. Instead of trying to find some perfect plan in advance, you know, just look backwards instead of forwards. See how things are going and then kind of keep adapting. Alright. words instead of four words see how things are going and then kind of keep adapting all right all right thank you so much for uh supporting the show um through patreon audible also through your emails um this actually was a recommendation but it's a recommendation from
文件之类的东西。所以就这样对待它，你知道的。与其试图提前找到某种完美的计划，不如向后看而不是向前看。看看事情进展如何，然后不断调整。好的。向后看而不是向前看，看看事情进展如何，然后不断调整，好的，好的，非常感谢你们通过Patreon、Audible以及你们的电子邮件支持这个节目，这实际上是一个推荐，但这是一个来自
over a year ago and um i was just going through, you know, old emails and, you know, specifically looking for show topics. I saw this one. I thought, oh, this is a great topic. It could really appeal to anybody. And so I honestly didn't keep track of who told me what, but whoever suggested this, thank you. And for people who send us emails, you know, replied us on Twitter, Facebook facebook so on and so forth um thank you so much for your feedback and financially obviously is great keeps the servers running keeps the lights running um lets us buy uh microphones and things like that so we can kind of reach out to more people so um thanks a lot and uh we'll see you next month the intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot
一年多前的推荐，我当时正在翻看旧邮件，专门寻找节目主题。我看到了这个。我想，哦，这是一个很棒的主题。它真的可以吸引任何人。所以我老实说没有记录是谁告诉我的，但无论谁建议了这个，谢谢你。对于那些给我们发邮件、在Twitter、Facebook等平台上回复我们的人，非常感谢你们的反馈，经济上的支持显然很棒，让服务器运行，让灯光亮着，让我们购买麦克风之类的东西，这样我们就可以接触到更多的人，所以，非常感谢，我们下个月见，片头音乐是Binar Pilot的Axo
programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to remix adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Programming Throwdown是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可下发布的，你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，以重新混合、改编作品，但你必须注明帕特里克和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。